foreign
you
okay sorry
we'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 1469 prohibiting banks or
businesses from using social credit
scores
good morning mr bernard
are we ready
yeah
well thank you chairman hunt and
committee members my name is uh jd
bernardi i'm representing rockingham 16
southampton kensington and east kingston
and i'm here to uh to sponsor 1469.
we'll start off with the concept of what
are esg scores
why did they come about who creates them
or what's gone and or going wrong with
them
so esg scores
is an evaluation of a firm's collective
consciousness
concerning social justice corporate
governance and environmental factors
they're a score that's compiled from
data collected using metrics related to
those various factors
they can be considered sort of a
corporate social credit score
and these three factors together
comprise an assessment that's been
adopted by many u.s
and worldwide financial industry uh
provide investment decisions
in addition to the company's bottom line
proponents claim that the ultimate
objective of these
metrics it relates to corporate
sustainability and assessing societal
impact of the company
so what are these factors environmental
factors include
a company's position on climate change
soil water contamination waste
management
renewable energy environmental policy
social justice scores involve business
relationships including diversity human
rights consumer protection
and interactions animal welfare
charitable contributions community
impact
governance scores evaluate legal and
compliance issues
associated with the company's
corporate operations including their
regulatory and legal compliance
management structure
employee and executive compensation
who creates these scores well they're
created by
organizations and analytical firms like
bloomberg corporate knights sustained
analytics dow jones
thompson reuters rep risk and others
and at this point
almost all businesses that exist of any
size have an esg score
and if esg scores were to remain just a
business tool for an investor to use in
deciding whether they wanted to invest
in a business or not
this bill wouldn't be being proposed
the bill specifically
permits the continued use of esg scores
for personal investment decisions
the problem addressed by this bill
is that there were there's a woke
movement that is attempting to weaponize
esg scores against companies and against
individuals
the world economic forum published their
esg metrics in a in a report entitled
measuring stakeholder capitalism toward
common metrics and consistent reporting
of sustainable value creation
this was released in september of 2020
and prepared by experts from the big
four accounting firms price
ernst young kpmg
and deloitte as well as the bank of
america it includes their 21 metrics and
32 expanded metrics
it divides these standards into pillars
governing principles of governance
principles of the planet of the people
and prosperity
it uses many of the same traditional esg
scores and some of these metrics are
very reasonable for any investor to use
but it also focuses on awoke ideology
criteria that are that are found in in
these scores
the goal of the world economic forum is
to mandate businesses focus their
corporate decision making on improving
their wokeness of their esg scores
rather than profitability or product
quality
this effort has been called the great
reset
it's fully described in glenn beck and
and justin haskins new book of the same
title
rise of 21st century
fascism
glenn and justin describe how groups
a group of
three dozen large investors activists
non-profits pension funds and former
politicians collectively manage over a
trillion dollars in assets have lobbied
the federal reserve
and the securities exchange commission
to fully adopt the woke esg criteria
in their corporate governance
ideas that are so good
the same is being pushed by three in the
big three index fund managers blackrock
vanguard and state street
these three firms
in 2017
had five percent of the s p
under their uh
tutelage
in in 2017 it was 20
and they're expected to have 40 of the s
s p votes in the next two decades
the big ten including j p morgan
fidelity and goldman sachs
are worth 34 trillion
and along with big tech are also
deeply involved in the esg movement and
openly support
the great reset
once the system is firmly in place
no business or industry will be able to
withstand the woke goals of the
governing elites
industries like oil and gas or your
firearms industry
all their suppliers
all their distributors
will be unable to get funding or
financing for further growth
and continued operations
and if you're a fabricator
as an example of the firing pin of that
particular gun that you like but you
also make a spindle for a weaving loom
your company is going to be under the
gun
the spread of the great resets esg's
fingers go deep into the system
there's little ability to stop the
global elites from manipulating society
and controlling political opponents with
the new additional metrics
because they're not done by government
they're being done by the elites
managing these companies
and it's not just corporations that are
going to be subject to the esg
system
individuals also have scores if you're
an investor and have any significant
assets in any uh
stocks you have an esg score
already
and it can easily be expanded by looking
at
your purchases by reviewing your credit
card or bank statements
so your non-woke purchases or stock
picks will give you a low esg score
so then when you want to take that car
loan or mortgage that activity is going
to be curtailed by the bank
if you work for an unfavored industry or
or are a supplier or a distributor to
one your score will be reduced
unfavored industries will lose good
employees
so if you think this can't happen to you
this is
hyperbole
just remember
deutsche bank and signature bank in new
york decided that they're no longer
going to do business with a former
president of the united states donald
trump
simon and schuster
canceled the publishing of senator john
holly's book the tyranny of big tech
parlor a new social media platform was
removed from service by apple google and
amazon
big tech has demonetized
censored and removed people from their
platforms because their management
doesn't agree with the opinions of those
people
all this is being done by the elites
managing these companies
not by government
so the problem with the issue scores is
the ability and the willingness to
weaponize them against individuals and
companies
using esg scores as a personal
investment tool is perfectly legitimate
weaponizing them against corporations
and individuals is not
such discriminatory discriminatory
the plans to implement to the great
resets tyranny exist
the mechanisms of all esg scores and
whatnot are in place the commitment of
major financial and corporate
institutions to mandate their vision of
wokeness against the politically
disfavored is being actively advanced
please do not permit this discrimination
in new hampshire please do not allow
weaponization of these techniques here
support hb 1469
to prevent
inestimable harm to the citizens of new
hampshire
thank you for coming before us and um
bringing this issue to us
you used the term woke movement and woke
um a number of times in your speech
so if you look at
if you look at the esg scores that
are being advanced so let's take
environmental scoring for example
climate change a judgment is being made
that if
uh
if if you aren't 100
supporting all electric vehicles you're
going to be downgraded because you're
not because you're advocating the
continued use of oil or diesel or
gasoline
powered
vehicles that's part of the woke
movement
i'm sorry i'm still not clear um you're
giving me an example of how the esg
score might be used but i don't
understand what you mean by woke
movement
woke a leftist movement uh a movement
that's focused on
picking winning winners and losers based
i think she's asking what does woke mean
what does woke what does woke mean
it does have a definition
uh
well i would i would characterize that
as i said as a leftist focused
assessment or belief in uh
technology business interpersonal
interactions i mean it's it's it's a
series of
if you look in these esg scores
uh let's take diversity if your if your
business uh
doesn't have the right ratio of all the
quote unquote right people in it if you
if you're a new hampshire business and
you have largely white men working for
you you're you're not woke
you need to have a bunch of women and a
bunch of minorities that don't ex that
you may not have the qualifications
because of this you know what exists in
this state
but you're not woke because
you don't meet that criteria
you keep saying political you're like
leftist
yes so that implies a wokism
is
leftist center
and wants to
[Music]
make decisions based upon their
political beliefs
and and that's fine one can have
whatever political belief you want
that's not the the purpose here the the
function the the discussion is about the
fact that collectively there's this
group of elites has decided
this is the way things are going to be
done and using
that point of view to force
decisions on everyone else
so if i understand correctly the
political elites that you're talking
about
are um
board of directors of a bank
or the president
the the officers as i mentioned we had
the the leaders of the big four
accounting firms bank of america
google apple uh you know making these
decisions
those leaders
have a
viewpoint that is
decidedly leftist and decidedly
anti-any maybe conservative or
intermediate position
and are
demanding compliance so
parlor disappeared because they had
their website or their their social
media site allowed any point of view to
happen it wasn't constrained to the
perfect
woke positions
so
to make sure i get this right okay
i'm focusing in on
the right of a corporation or issue a
bank
to decide
that
they are going now to be political
because they're leftists
and they want to
affect their political agenda
on someone who has come to them for a
bank loan
yes
and the question is
that how do we that this is their
perspective this is their opinion
what you're telling me is that
we the legislature are going to say is
that you're not allowed
to have a political opinion
when it comes to your business
activities
i'm saying you're not allowed to
discriminate against individuals because
of their political opinion
so
if you're going to get that bank loan
yet you're a gun owner
and you
show up at the pta meeting and you say
you don't want
critical race theory being taught
your your individual score is going to
be downgraded and under the esg system
because you are not woke
and therefore we the bank are going to
use that criteria against you in not
giving you the car loan they're not
giving you the mortgage they're not
going to look at what is your ability to
repay the loan
as a normal bank would i'm going to give
you a loan
here's the criteria can you pay this
loan back do you have the wherewithal
and income stream to pay that loan back
that's what a bank ought to be looking
at not my politics in deciding whether i
am worthy to get that loan so you cannot
the bill basically says you may not
discriminate based on that those kinds
of criteria
so um i obviously
i sit on a family foundation
and
esg has been around for
years years
there is the scoring system of an esg
is um
you're getting scored on your positives
what you are doing
on those esg categories
i've never seen an esg analysis to
use to
degrade a company's value that it's
always is this is what they are doing
not what they're not doing i guess
how does someone
know what their esg score is
how does someone how does someone
evaluate that score and and how does the
bank department i guess as i assume
i i don't even know how how this is
going to get enforced but
is that
they're going to have to
rule that there's some kind of evidence
some kind of scoring system that they
can get their hands on that documents
that this said someone was harmed
by this scoring system
so
how does
how do you understand how does one get
the score so all the the the the
companies that exist virtually all
companies of any size
are scored and i went through the
various uh stock owned companies these
are these are publicly traded yes
whether it be banks or other you know
companies they have esg scores
and they are rated on those criteria and
if you're an oil company
you're not going to have a good sgs esg
score if you're a firearms company
you're not going to have a good esg
score if you are any other unfavored
industry you're not going to have a good
esg score and as an individual
if you are an investor in those
investors are also being scored and so
individuals get esg scores what kind of
companies did you invest in
so if you own
so how does someone see that score how
does someone get that number where where
is this number published or where where
does someone get this or is this is that
a secret secret
right right now if you uh if you're an
investor in merrell uh in merrill lynch
merrill lynch has a score for your
investments
it does you personally have that score
right so that so when i contact my bank
you know they contact me and
and if i were to ask them okay what is
the esg scores of those of these
businesses
they're going to make it and as i hear
from you you're telling me that's
perfectly okay
but now what you're saying is but if
i'm a bank
and i'm looking at those scores
that
this legislation would
perceive that that if i don't give a
loan to an institute to somebody
i could be
guilty of this
simply because that that business is
perceived to have
that score but you're holding that
financial institution responsible
simply because they didn't give the loan
well if you don't get a loan from the
bank the bank has to tell you why you
didn't get the loan
right they go over and say all right we
looked at your financials
mr smith
you you don't have the wherewithal to
pay this money back you don't have a
credible income stream
okay don't have a collateral so if they
if they say that
that's fine and if they can demonstrate
that that's fine
but if they're using esg criteria to say
you you you bought a sig sauer last week
and your bank your
we have your credit card statement
we're not giving loans to people like
you
that is the discrimination i'm talking
about you think something could actually
do that they would actually say we know
that you bought
a gun and we're not giving you the loan
because you think some bank would do
that
yes that is the goal of the great reset
that is the advertised prescribed goal
of the members of these organizations
saying we want to implement these
criteria on the management decisions of
companies
as well as on individuals
it is is it here right now no the system
is set up esg scores and what not
ability to evaluate is set up so
mechanically it can be turned on and it
then the idea is it will be turned on
and their goal is to have this in place
by 2030.
great
uh
representative mclaren um
uh thank you for your testimony
you you seem to blame this all on
the left
is is it possible that a group on the
right would have the same woke attitude
about companies or is it only on the
left
it's certainly possible that you know
the the criteria could be used uh
equivalently
from the from the right that that that's
not the the subject of the
you know of the
of the bill the idea is you should not
be able to use political
decision-making criteria in making
decisions to make uh your financial uh
financial decisions
to
establish these esg scores
i mean
i'm not saying there's a conspiracy i'm
saying that esg scores the concept of
sustainability esg scores has been
created and has been used by investors
there's no problem with that because
that's your choice
or my choice if i want to invest in
stocks that have high esg scores based
on the kind of criteria that are being
proposed or being
evaluated that's fine and if i want to
change those criteria and say i want esg
scores that look at
more
conservative focused criteria and and
make decisions on my business that way
or
or who i'm going to deal with you can do
that
because those are personal decisions
okay well i got a scenario for you
so human rights
groups
have identified certain companies
the united states that are
using chinese
child labor work labor you know the uh
criminal let's say criminal activity you
know the people who are uh injured we
your labor
okay
so if
someone says i'm not going to invest in
that company because of that report
uh
if that
is
if an individual wants to make that
decision the individual has the right to
do that but a business
this is a business giving a loan to that
corporation that business this is a bank
that wants to loan you know that this
company's come to her alone
and they're saying is well we don't want
to do business with you because
you have we don't want to do business
with nike because nike's using uyghur
labor there you go
uh that would be uh yes that would be an
act if that is the sole reason
that they give all right well it's just
a one of the many
you've got all the metrics as far as the
financials you pass we can get we'll
give you the loans so we're assuming
nike is a financially sound company yeah
yeah and that but the bank says no we're
not going to loan to you because of this
situation in china
and therefore they should be guilty of
this of this bill that would be yeah
that would be discrimination
that way yes okay
any other question representative
i i think that um thank you mr chair i
think um mr chair you alluded to the
idea that how would the banking
department
how would the witch say in
how would the banking department monitor
and enforce this bill
well
again if you were if you were requesting
a loan
as a business or
as an individual you're going to get a
reason why
your loan was possible to be
given or not
and if it's if it can't be given
because of
some of some criteria beyond
financials
now now they they have to tell you that
and so now you have the ability to
report that to the banking industry and
say
i'm not i'm being discriminated against
because of this
it's going to have to be a claim made by
the individual based on
on the
report from
from those denied services
in the case that you're talking about
uh i think you're a co-sponsor so you
can't
you can't ask questions now
you can testify
but you can't ask questions
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you chair will uh
call on
representative who's in support of the
bill
good morning
mr chairman and members of the committee
thank you for
accepting my testimony here this morning
i did send
to every member of the committee earlier
today a copy of
the highlights from my testimony i don't
tend to write out
my testimony i speak
extemporaneously
from
notes and these are the notes that i
sent you earlier today
i want to focus my ten
well i should start out by saying that i
am for the record representative michael
vose
i represent rockingham district 9 the
town of epping and i serve as chair of
the science technology and energy
committee and i want to focus my
testimony this morning on
the
aspect of esg
that i found find most troubling and
that is
its
promotion
of the divestiture of fossil fuels
as a way to combat
climate change
now i've done a lot of reading and
studying about climate change over the
years
and it's become clear to me
that
the science is far from settled science
is never settled in fact
and that
there is no way to say definitively
that
carbon dioxide is the control knob of
the climate
there's just too much research out there
that says that isn't so
but even though
the media narrative is that
carbon dioxide
is the culprit
it's too complex a question for the
media to grapple with so they they latch
onto that idea and promote it
even though
its validity in the scientific
literature is being
but if you
believe
that
carbon dioxide is causing climate change
and we humans are burning fossil fuels
and increasing the amount of carbon
dioxide that there is in the atmosphere
you might conclude
that
stopping the burning of fossil fuels
and the esg
movement
is moving in the direction of trying to
convince companies to divest
their investments in the fossil fuel
industry
and one of the
that movement
is the net zero banking alliance
which is a
consortium
of
instant institutions from around the
that
seeks to
encourage
the divestiture of
investments in fossil fuels by 2050.
currently the net zero banking alliance
had includes seven of the largest and
most influential banks in the united
states including bank of america city
jpmorgan chase morgan stanley goldman
sachs wells fargo and amalgamated bank
together these banks control over 66
trillion dollars in assets
these banks are seeking to use their
influence and they use esg scores as
part of that influence
funds that invest in fossil fuels to
divest
those investments
so retirement funds for example that
invest in fossil fuels
the net zero banking alliance would
discourage
those retirement funds from investing in
well why does that matter
could collapse
the fossil fuel industry
and the collapse of the fossil fuel
industry
would kill more people
the world runs on fossil fuel fuels
85 of our energy comes from fossil fuels
if we collapse the fossil fuel market
through financial manipulation
such as that
envisioned by the net zero banking
alliance
will destabilize the world
killed millions possibly even billions
of people
and
create
instability and chaos
that's why i think
bills such as this one
that
discourage discrimination based on esg
criteria
are absolutely necessary
for us to
prevent
a calamity in the world
now climate change
may turn out to be a problem
that's still an open question
but it won't even if it does turn out to
be a problem it won't be nearly as big a
problem as we would have
if the fossil fuel industry collapsed
because of the manipulations
such as those that are members of the
net zero banking alliance
so i urge the committee to give serious
consideration to passing this
legislation
if it needs amendment to make it
enforceable
to make it applicable
then i encourage you to
work with the bill sponsor to find
those amendments
that's uh my testimony for this morning
oh we do have a question
if i can ask this question is it's about
the fiscal note
would that be
boys and means or
uh
you could
just
there's there is a fiscal note there is
a fiscal note yes so what's in fiscal
notes did you
yes
um
not
if you read indeterminate right
but um could you
there is a fiscal note
confused
in that you would be
presenting a bill to
this committee that has a fiscal note to
no that's not a question no can you just
that's asking his your hearts and minds
you know then well i'm surprised i'm
shocked that you would
you know no we don't ask questions like
that that's not a question
you're asking his motivation no we do
not ask people their motivation
i'm just i'm just talking about the
fiscal note
there is a fiscal note and the physical
note says zero so that means there
shouldn't be any problem and i would
remind the
member that
fiscal notes are
not something that the bill sponsor has
anything to do with a fiscal note is a
determination by the speaker's office
and the legislative budget assistance
office
that there might be some financial
impact of the bill and they try to
assess what that is but it has nothing
to do with the bill sponsor
all right thank you
yes
representative johnson thank you for
taking my question
um do you have actual evidence of
discrimination
of this nature of this bill against
individuals or businesses based on esg
scores
well if you consider the fact that the
net zero banking alliance is encouraging
retirement funds to divest of fossil
fuels i'd say that's evidence yes
thank you
further question further question
is the government officially
participating in the world economic
forum
the world economic forum
i don't know the answer to that
i suspect not but
it could be there is a link at the
bottom of the testimony that i submitted
to the committee
that explains what the net zero banking
alliance is and how it operates and how
it works
i encourage you to visit that link and
learn more about the net zero
thank you
representative mclair
uh yes uh
i'm looking at your notes here
and uh down at the bottom it says the
end game and it says there lies the path
to collectivism could you elaborate on
that
yes
what that bullet basically means is that
if you look at the economy of china
it is a
watered-down version of capitalism
called collectivism
so the government doesn't own
the means of production
as it would in a traditional communist
society
the chinese government allows
individual chinese citizens to own
businesses
but it then basically tells people how
they can run their businesses what they
can and can't do
to the extent that the government
essentially controls business and that's
collectivism
and the great reset to capitalism as
described in the book referred to by the
previous speaker
describes how
we're on the road to a similar sort of
collectivism
and that the esg score
mechanism
which is
representative hunt pointed out has been
around for a long time
is a mechanism that can be manipulated
okay thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you
uh the chair will call on
uh christy merrill
representing the new hampshire bankers
association
good morning mr chair and honorable
members of the house commerce committee
my name is christy merrill i'm president
of the new hampshire bankers association
we represent 38 member banks which
employ nearly 6 000 employees
and we're here today to oppose the
legislation there's been a lot of
conversation about
the esg scores
and it's been very fascinating to listen
to but i'm really going to just focus my
comments on the legislation
which really focuses on the title talks
about social credit scores so um we
actually agree with the sponsor that
banks and businesses should not
discriminate based on subject subjective
and arbitrary standards like social
media posts
we are concerned however that the
legislation will do more harm than good
and will invite frivolous lawsuits by
any disgruntled bank customer
the title of the bill suggests that it's
focused on social credit scores
but it actually goes much more beyond
that specifically 14 house bill 1469
would prohibit banks and other
businesses from discriminating against
any person or business based on
subjective or arbitrary standards such
as social media posts affiliations with
clubs and and it goes on
on its face that may not seem
controversial but there's a few things i
want to point out that we think are
really problematic with the legislation
the legislation does not define
discrimination in any way
nor does it define the phrase adverse
treatment
as a result
we're of the opinion that it will most
certainly invite litigation against
banks and other financial institutions
with such an broad and opened
terminology it leaves the door wide open
for any citizen whether they're an
employee a customer otherwise to bring a
complaint against a bank for any
perceived discrimination or adverse
treatment
and this would put the bank in a very
difficult position of trying to disprove
an allegation that a decision was based
on subjective standards
when you couple that with the hefty
fines that are in the legislation this
undoubtedly will subject banks to
significant litigation for any conduct
that might be perceived as
discriminatory
i'd also like to point out that the
phrase business practices on page 1
lines 12-13 that's also not defined and
so
it's not clear what's included but as
it's drafted it would likely be
interpreted to include hiring or
and a last point that i think is is
really important is that we believe this
bill is unnecessary because banks are
already subjected to extensive
regulation which prohibit prohibit
discrimination in several ways
for example the community reinvestment
act
the fair credit reporting act the equal
credit opportunity act and the fair
housing act they all prohibit
discrimination in various contexts
and i just want to go a little deeper on
what's known as the cra the community
reinvestment act
when they're examined regular regulators
specifically examine banks to evaluate
whether a bank is engaging in
discriminate discriminatory or other
legal conduct in lending which includes
a review of the nature extent and
strength of the evidence of the
practices the policies and the
procedures that the bank or savings
association has in place to prevent the
practices
and any corrective action that the
banker or savings association has taken
or committed to take including voluntary
corrective action resulting from
self-assessment and other any other
relevant information
and we've got the federal citation for
that um these provisions that's in
addition to
all of the other requirements that
businesses and employers are already
subject to that prohibit discrimination
such as the ada the adea the equal pay
act and the civil rights act
so in in some we agree that new
hampshire banks oppose discrimination as
should all businesses um however our we
have objections with this legislation um
and we believe there are serious
consequences
with some of these open-ended provisions
that they could pose for our members and
so for those reasons we oppose the
legislation and we would respectfully
so if i understand your testimony
correctly that the anti-discrimination
law now
in place could be used if someone felt
that they bank
didn't give him a loan because he just
bought a sig saucer a week ago
we banks are already subject to those
did you want to ask a question oh yes so
uh
representative abel you have a question
uh this is a question of the chair
actually uh will the banking department
be testifying because if so i may i may
uh ask this question later i i have no
all right she can't testify to ask a
question
no i'll ask it to uh okay yes i'll ask
it
to christy
miss merrell
the
as i understand that the
new hampshire banking department
only
oversees
state banks banks that are incorporated
here
if this legislation were to go into
effect
what would be the impact on
banks
that are foreign banks
that are
or even state banks that are that are
federally federally regulated um thank
you for the question representative um
it's our understanding that the banking
department regulates others other
institutions as well besides just state
chartered banks but i think that's a
good question it's not clear to us based
on where this statute lies and these
provisions lie as to how that how that
relates to federally chartered banks and
if this would only apply to state
any other questions
xenon thank you thank you oh did you
have a question i'm sorry
all right
i believe i heard
earlier in your testimony
that you had a concern
and therefore were opposed to
this legislation as presented
on the basis of there being no
definition of discrimination that's
line four
it it seems to me my reading
that discrimination
is defined as being based on esg scores
is there something i'm missing here
because esg scores by their very nature
reference criteria
and standards
in order to determine such a score
and the way i read this sentence
discrimination is based
upon that score
the utilization
of that score
so i'm a little perplexed and wish that
you could clarify that and elaborate
please sure um so
section one is the purpose statement and
so you're right it does have that
explanation that elaborates on
discrimination being based on
such scores
but
it does not amend any statute and so as
a purpose statement i don't know that
that is a binding definition
there are further in that section too
there there are further kind of examples
of discrimination um and it kind of
describes it but it's not clear that it
actually defines what discrimination is
follow up please further question me
inquire
so would it satisfy your concern
that discrimination is
not defined
within the subparagraphs of
the rsa that is cited in line 9 be
satisfied if in fact
discrimination was defined
yeah somewhere in
section two
as discrimination based on esg scores
would that not remedy your concern
um representative i'd be happy to take a
look at that i think that would improve
upon some of the concerns that we have
but as we mentioned we still do have
other concerns there are other terms
that are not defined and we also don't
believe it's necessary can i finalize
here please with respect to that
particular
uh concern would you follow up with me
please and the committee and address
that concern in writing
representative are you asking me to
define discrimination no i'm asking you
whether what i proposed would in fact
satisfy your concern that discrimination
is not defined
i as i you're saying you don't have the
ability to do that yourself
would you after in consultation and
study with colleagues be able to get
back to me and and give me an answer i'm
certainly happy to look at anything that
you want to share with us representative
thank you uh well i just did thank you
yeah i i think it's best that you email
her your exact
uh resolute what you think is the way to
resolve that question
and then you want me to reiterate what i
said i don't know
i'm just we're relying on the clerk i
guess we could re-see the tape we can
watch the tape but i think the best
thing to do is you to spell out exactly
what your question is
and then email it to her and all of us
or you know
and then we can make sure that they
address that when we do the subcommittee
thank you i will do
so anyone else
see
thank you very much
okay
so you will filled out a card for us
are we all set
representative abel are you all set do
you still need the banking department to
no no no i don't okay great
okay i got one card left uh betty grande
gran
from
good morning good morning mr chairman
and members of the committee thank you
for this opportunity to be in front of
you i was asked by representative vas to
come today to just give you information
regarding
i am betty grandy
it's norwegian not spanish so grandy
and
is a national think tank yet we work on
the state level in each and every state
helping with the
discovery development and promotion of
free market solutions in the social and
economic problems
facing today focusing on providing
national state and local officials with
reliable and timely research and
analysis on important
this bill addresses a growing insidious
undermining threat to the freedom and
association investment of
your constituents and private businesses
in your state this is a far too evidence
today to dismiss this as conspiracy
theories
as stated so well in the declaration of
purpose in this particular bill
this is a matter of state concern that
directly impacts your citizens and
private businesses in new hampshire
just two years ago it would be hard to
imagine any citizens
access to banking insurance travel goods
services
that would be restricted in any way
the freedoms and liberties are are so
great in our in our states and in our in
our nation
but we are starting to see this happen
mr chairman i will say i've been
studying this issue and testified across
the
states
dealing with esg issues for a couple of
years now this is probably one of the
better written
pieces of legislation as a former
legislator of 18 years in north dakota i
i've seen a bit and written a bit and
and i i really like the wording of this
much better than the direction other
so in this and i and i do believe i
barry i can't i'm sorry i can't see the
name terry
um
his point of moving that purpose
statement i think is is is well heard i
i agree with that type of thing
i would say that as it's being in the
declaration
above
does give legislative intent so once the
intent is in place then that does direct
the bill
even though it's not written into the
language
so
well well point well made
so in first learning about social credit
systems is a couple years ago as i was
reading about some things in china that
were taking place
the choices actions and interactions of
individuals in china are so closely
monitors and the scores are based on
these arbitrary
subjective standards set up by their
government
in in this
at a time that i thought this type of
thing would never happen here it is
starting to happen
and so in china what they have is they
have a system where they can actually
monitor your eyes and so if you're out
on the street they see who you're
talking to
if you're shopping and you stop and you
look at a particular article a
product
your scores are automatically rolling
back and forth
through what the government has set up
for those standards
and so there are criterias that are in
place in other nations we are not to
that point thank goodness and yet
the availability of that type of thing
is there and so just just so you're
aware that um this isn't something new
it isn't something somebody just made up
as a conspiracy thing
um even on even in our weakened form of
federalism and state autonomy the state
cannot
fully control behaviors choices and
actions of our citizens
exert far more control than many of us
have ever really realized and i think
we've seen that over the last couple
years
the growing threat to individual
freedoms and liberty is not coming from
the government alone but from the
collusion of the government with these
large corporations
and so more and more we are seeing large
businesses money-centered banks
insurance companies and airlines
implementing efforts to steer the
economy and the choices of the citizens
with the nodding approval and privilege
provided to them by our govern
government
this is stated in their mission
statements and so mr chairman if you
would would like later i can send to you
to pass along to the committee the
mission statements of bank of america
blackrock lloyd's of london and
wells fargo i happen to have those with
me they specifically state how they are
monitoring and how they want to do this
so well why does that matter to new
hampshire
as our banking person just stated
they have their
things they're going to follow well
their funding or their backing comes
from an fdic
these will also then are the money comes
from the big guys down to the little
guys so if these guys say well we're not
going to give you money to loan we're
not going to offer and back the
insurance
applications that you're wanting to
approve
then they can't do that work
it's a top-down thing and it and it does
happen it's happening in
we've seen it
in our coal industry in north dakota
where our coal companies were seen on a
quarterly basis their insurance go up
and up and up and up and why was that
because
lloyds of london were saying we are
going to divest from fossil fuel
so they weren't allowing insurance to
take place in those
they're not allowing these things to be
insured or and by doing that instead of
saying we're not going to insure you
we're just going to jack your rates
so
this is this is not china
but because we have the safeguards
against it
but if access to banking credit cards
loans and travel and our goods and
services are restricted from this
top-down subjective measuring stick
how is it any different than a state
employees post restrictions the results
from individual citizens is the same
as well documented in the book that was
referred to
earlier the great reset my colleague
from the heartland institute justin
haskins one of the co-authors with glenn
beck
have been monitoring social media on esg
the environmental social governance
movement to social credit scoring
it is all interconnected
the results is less choice less freedom
and a dimming of the american dream for
the average citizen
this is not some boogie man from the
future it is here in 2019
the article
by the world economic forum which was
spoken apart
just recently introduced a credit card
that will track the carbon footprint as
you spend and will cut off your spending
once you reach their arbitrary carbon
limit that's mastercard has done that
now you can choose not to have that
mastercard
but
it's the wave of the future we've all
seen things happen where this guy's it's
the test run
and then they will move to everybody
having to follow this carbon footprint
less than a year ago cbs market watch
ran an article stating that mastercard
will track it and that that type of
spending and if you should have received
my testimony you will have links to both
of those within the electronic testimony
please feel free to follow back up don't
take my word for it read it yourself
the
best way to protect the freedoms and the
choices of our citizens and and in the
great state of new hampshire
these subjective standards
on how we should live our lives need to
be protected we need to protect our
local businesses our local independent
banks from this coercion and the
leverage of the suppliers and
correspondent relationships
having served in the north dakota
legislature for over 18 years
but i never saw this type of an
insidious over overtaking
in in my time of the freedoms of our
choices and our liberties today
we are an enter north dakota is an
energy and agricultural producing state
you guys are very agricultural too
and with that these are direct targets
of this
call it what you like but the impacts on
our lives will be
in our contingent constituents
from the collusion of these large
businesses federal government cannot be
ignored
for more information you may check out
the heartland institute or the
heartland.org
climaterealism.com
and climate at a glance dot com those
are all in my testimony so you can look
those up on the climate at a glance you
have the opportunity to download a
digital book that will give you
the the bullet points of the scientific
uh information that backs this so
there's always the scientific link in
each of those
based by done by and
written by scientists so
i want to thank you mr chair and the
committee
and if you upon your request i can send
i
i will stand for question but a couple
of just quick answer some of the
questions that were coming up um
if i can remember them all here
yes the the rating system is in place
we've seen it in the coal industry
already
so yes this is happening
um
yes we are involved in the world
economic forum i don't recall who asked
that
john kerry is our person
that has been attending and is our
so-called spokesperson for that
thank you mr chairman
thank you we do have a question from
representative terry
yes uh thank you ma'am and thank you for
uh
your testimony
in making your way from one
frozen state to another frozen state to
do so today
uh once again uh as with the my prior
question
uh i'd like to reference
something that you said early on in your
testimony
um i believe that you described
communist china's esgs as arbitrary and
would you would you also be in agreement
particularly with reference to
how they are determined
and perhaps in contrast to the common
understanding of the word arbitrary
patently ideological
philosophical
and political
and further
the
design of a command-and-control
economy in society
thank you mr chairman and representative
terry
when when china has set this up they're
setting it up for control of their
citizens through their government
opinions so a lot of what they are
ranking theirs on
are on um political uh standout so if
you're not uh following their political
ideals
that what they utilize it mostly for is
their means of purchase and
transportation is all in a chip form
and so if i my score gets too low my
chip won't let me on the bus
if my chip score gets too low or they
want to
prevent me from purchasing a particular
thing
my chip won't work for the purpose
in that purchase
now we're not to that extreme
but when a country
that large
that is gaining this much control is
taking
it
we need to be
aware
and
have i addressed that correctly quick
follow-up then with respect to the uh
the the the esg applications here in
this country at this time
would you agree that there is some at
least some element of ideology
philosophy and and and political element
mr chairman and representative terry
yes
and especially with the esg and on the
environmental side
if you are expanding your carbon
footprint too far
then you will be cut off on your finance
side or your insurance rates will be
raised
and that that is what the ranking is and
that's what the purpose statements are
within those major organizations that
are forming this
they are granted this ability to do it
in the cooperation from when president
um
biden
passed a meet almost immediately upon
entering
executive order 14008
and that executive order said all
agencies
all are to start adhering and reviewing
everything to this
direction
uh representative we're pretty late so
you're gonna make it a real short
we're just the heartland institute you
don't have anything to do with the
heartland institute of financial
representative johnson has a question
yes thank you
is there an effort to make the federal
reserve a depository bank
mr chairman and representative johnson
the the goal
the final goal in all of this is to have
everything in a centralized bank all
banking going centralized
further question
um what is uh
with that is
individuals
can can they open up a federal reserve
like they can in the in the bank of new
mr chairman representative johnson i am
unaware
sorry i can't answer that thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you uh having no more cards and
being hopelessly late oh you want to
speak
oh i thought you weren't going to be
here
i'm sorry nina i didn't recognize you uh
yeah normally you have to be you know
sitting i know i couldn't find it well i
know there's a bunch of them here i
apologize
except two quick questions um
in terms of the you mentioned the
insurance rates going up for the fossil
fuel industry i'm curious to know how do
you know that that's related to social
credit scores and not maybe just a
function of that there are more there's
more litigation in the fossil fuel
industry these days
um i am mr chairman and
representative
pharaohs um
i am going by what i have been told by
our
industry
that is in conversation with the
director of the industry that is how he
related it to me
follow up for the question man claire
yeah this is another subject
in section two
g1 you know there's mention of um social
media participation clubs associations
and i guess i i don't know if you can
answer it or somebody else
how would this relate if somebody let's
say it's a hypothetical situation
somebody was posting about terrorist
activities against the u.s government
should that be taken into account
in looking at social credit scores
mr chairman and representative
um as a person who didn't directly write
this piece of legislation i'm only
testifying on the overall importance of
it
i would say that when you get to the
disclaimer at the bottom of point one
um physical safety i think if you want
to take that into
uh
effect there and if it needs to be
clarified or explain expanded
i think the bill sponsor would be the
one to direct that too thank you
all right thank you very much thank you
okay i will close the public hearing on
house bill 1469 and i believe i see the
sponsor of 12 37
and
anybody else would like to testify in
1237 please get a pink card into me
thank you mr chair
yes representative christie good morning
i just wanted to introduce um two uh
representatives that are um sitting in
and substituting for representatives
um connie van houten and for tina fargo
who couldn't be out because of illness
[Music]
maria perez from milford so is this
going to happen more often is that the
reason why they're here because we would
never be executing anything today um
i understand um i don't have the answer
to that at this time um both both of
these um
just be able to be we're not vote we
don't in commerce or at least as long as
i am chairman
i have never voted on any bill on the
same day in which we've heard it
i believe every bill deserves 24 hours
so
so we would if we were to exec a bill it
would be published in the in the
calendar and when our exact date so but
it's great to have you here and and get
up to speed on
some of the things that we do here in
commerce thanks very much welcome
thank you thank you very much
okay
all right we'll open up the hearing and
hear from the prime sponsor
representing clear and okay so i'm all
set mr chairman the red button can
everybody hear me yes we can okay good
and i'm i'm okay even with my mask i
just want to be sure everybody hear me
uh again for the record i am state
representative john cloutier from
sullivan county district 10 which
comprises the entire city of claremont
and i'm here today as the prime sponsor
and in favor of house bill 1237 which is
relative cigar to cigar bars in other
words if house bill 12 37 becomes law
the amount of revenue from a business
establishment in order to qualify as a
cigar bar would at least be temporarily
lowered from 60 to 30 percent
and frankly i introduced this bill at a
request of a claremont constituent who
is concerned about the impact of house
bill 392 which passed in 2009
and is now law which requires that 60 of
all revenue from cigar bars be from the
sale of cigars
he believes this well-intentioned bill
that ice voted for has adversely
affected certain cigar bars in our state
and forced them to modify their
businesses in order to not to lose their
licenses
and uh you know he he i communicated
with him in an email especially in
september of last year he mentioned that
a specific nashua cigar bar i'm not
going to mention the business by name
right now but i
later on if you want i can share the
email to support his assertion
along with the challenges of the coven
19 pandemic which is we all know has
negatively impact many bars restaurants
and hotels
he believes that state government should
be revising some of the provisions of
house bill 392 so as to allow cigar bars
to compete with other eating and
drinking establishments
also he believes that revising the cigar
bar law would allow our constituents to
gather in such establishments of their
choice
reduce roadside litter which is an
environment i'm very concerned about as
well as generate a little bit more
revenue in cigar and liquor sales now as
you may understand from reading the
provisions of 12 house bill 1237 it is a
temporary revision of house bill 392
a temporary revision of our of the
current 13 year
cigar bar law that would reduce the
revenue requirement in half for two
years only
if house bill 1230 37 became law and
state government discovered it wasn't
helping cigar bars
reducing roadside litter and cruising
revenue then we could always return to
the original provisions of house bill
392. in fact this legislature would have
to approve additional legislation either
as a separate bill or an amendment to
existing bills in order to keep house
bill 1237 as written
and i just want to close with criminis
of information i'm not a user of cigars
or other tobacco products of any kind i
don't frequent bars
including cigar guards on a regular
basis generally i do like my light
consumption of alcohol beverages at home
normally this isn't the type of bill i
would sponsor
along with representative stapleton my
co-sponsor but i believe my constituent
has raised some important concerns about
our present cigar bar law
therefore i urge this committee to give
careful consideration of house bill 1237
hey representative bartlett thanks very
much mr chair
good morning representative morning
would you please detail how reducing the
revenue from cigar bars would reduce
roadside litter
well mike my constituent again in his
email he's mentioned he's seen since the
the the passage of this law and
especially since the pandemic he sees an
increase of bottles and cans along our
roadsides and in claremont and i i guess
throughout the state this is what he
mentioned to me i don't know
for the question main choir um please
elaborate you you're repeating what he
said to you but he must have given you a
reason of why there's more bottles and
cans on the side
okay thank you i i think because people
are not you know and it's it's partly
due to the pandemic and the emergency
restrictions
uh do you know the emer but basically
people have been gathering those those
places so instead
they're going in in private homes or
even they're out and i know in my air
which is a very rural area of our state
people do a lot of drinking in the cra
and out you know outdoors especially
people maybe even younger people who
really shouldn't be drinking anyway
and they're going along and they're
going out in the woods and parks boat
landings et cetera i know from this
experience
you know that that that especially our
younger people do this they really
really shouldn't be doing it but and
some of them are adults probably who can
legally drink but they don't really have
a lot of places these days because of
the pandemic
and so the roadside this is and i can i
can believe it myself
further and quieter thanks very much
so you're saying there's a direct result
between the reduction of the
revenue in a cigar bar and the
increase in
roadside litter
and that this is going to solve the
problem okay it will not it is just one
facet i think we need to do a lot of
things which probably you know i don't
want to get off on other bills and other
subjects it's a tough one to prove
okay all right i see your point
representative thank you
yes i can hear go ahead please
i i have not myself uh my as i said
uh i uh to be honest with you i have not
as of today
just to remind members just like when we
were on zoom we always gotta
turn the mic on
you push the the button
there's a big bar yep
yeah representative abel
uh yes thank you for testifying you're
welcome
cigar bars
in earlier years
have been given special
exemptions
including
tax exemptions
and
one
and i guess
you're speaking for your constituent but
but
if if this committee decided that they
that it was necessary to
uh
change
either the license or the tax situation
or something what do you think would be
the effect
depending on what how the the tax and
you're talking about the situation the
state level right not the federal level
representatives yes at the state level
because obviously the federal could do
something and
we couldn't do that much about it if if
we
change some of the state taxes i would
assume maybe their revenue would go up
some
liquor revenue some and i realize preem
i guess non-premium and premium are
taxed and i don't think preems and i'll
admit i'm a little confused about that
but they're taxed differently as i
understand it so that's
that aspect you know i think it's uh may
not be affected but i uh some changes in
our tax laws
and exemptions for you know might
increase the revenue but i put this
forward because of a concern about this
bill which which i supported by the way
i want to be clear i have nothing
against it in principle but i think it's
good from time after 13 years we take a
look
at the cigar bar law see if it's working
if it's working fine you can itl this
bill if it's not working you know maybe
you ought to take this bill and i trust
the wisdom of the committee to maybe i
don't know maybe make the whatever
change any of the cons items you see fit
but at least
i would say hope this committee would do
a study of the cigar bar law see if it's
working
and at least
you know if something if it's
let's say the itl i can always tell mike
the legislature tried
you know looked at your your concern but
it felt it was it was working properly
but if it it is not working properly
then
i feel that you know some changes ought
to be in mind because i try to
in in filing bills and i file a number
of bills that requ constituents request
because i think that's part of my duty
as a representative and some of them
pass some of them don't
uh but i think i'm i'm trying to be open
here and i want to in my closing
statement this is not normally the type
of bill i would sponsor but my
constituent in his email mate and i also
asked him to submit written testimony by
email he can't be here today
to help i mean i can
submit a copy of his email to the
committee if you want
uh
later on and i don't know please do
you're gonna do a subcommittee or
anything he will do a subcommittee and
please have him sent okay i will try try
to do that i did send
a copy of your email address i don't
know i guess as of this morning hadn't
submitted it because i wanted a copy he
did submit a um email but he did yes he
did and so i'm just keith ott all right
yeah right mr ott that is correct and i
don't know if i can identify specific
people
but he did some good i'm glad he did
submit that but i also can submit his
email he sent me in september that'll be
fine we're all set then all right okay
thank you mr chairman thank you
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony okay thank you very much mr
chairman your time and listening to me
okay so um we have lieutenant matthew
culver and aiden moore from the liquor
commission
good morning mr chairman committee
members good morning make sure that the
other mic's on okay you just have to
make sure the mic is close to you
whoever's talking all right thank you
um my name is aiden moore i'm the legal
coordinator for the state liquor
commission
with me is lieutenant matt culver who
oversees the administration within the
commission
we're here jointly to speak to this bill
lieutenant culver
has a great deal of data
which might be of interest to the
committee if there are follow-up
questions
we are
in opposition and we don't generally
come out and oppose policy questions but
this is uh represents a potential change
to the way that
the state policy is around alcohol
granted covid was difficult for many
many businesses
but it didn't prompt a significant
number of requests to change the
eligibility laws for those businesses
simply because of the pandemic
we we have some concerns also that by
reducing the requirement from 60 to 30
percent
it will bring additional businesses
in to that market area which is not
necessarily a bad thing
but at the end of two years
if they are not able to achieve the 60
figure
then we are
setting them up for failure where we're
going to have that license probably
taken away
simply because of their failure to
maintain the eligibility standards
associated with the law
so
we would recommend and request
that the statute remain as it is
without making this change
oversees
the quarterly inspections of these
businesses
and he can speak very directly to
the points about eligibility how how
evaluations of those
businesses take place
and
those procedures if if you would like
would you like to hear from him first
sir oh that'd be great
happy to do it
good morning thank you mr chairman and
fellow uh committee members
currently in the state of new hampshire
we have 15
cigar bar licenses issued throughout the
state
only one of those
licensees are not currently in
compliance with this 60 percent
quarterly gross revenue
uh requirements
so the way the current law reads is
sixty percent of the quarterly gross
revenue
has to come from
cigars or cigar related products cigar
related products are specifically
defined by statute and they include
six items
cigars
cigar boxes
humidors
uh yes so there's six items there uh
and
that quarterly gross revenue
has to meet the sixty percent
requirement anything else that they sell
um in their businesses actually works
against
the 60 requirement right so if you were
to
let's say sell a thousand dollars worth
of revenue
in your business
600 of that would have to come from
cigars or cigar related products
so
the reporting requirements for each of
the licensees uh
has to be
done on a quarterly basis so that each
quarter every three months licensees
submit to the division of enforcement
uh the quarterly reports for the
previous quarter
in that we determine
what those figures are and what they
represent
our auditing department examines those
examines invoices that come in examines
the sales that have come out and how
those sales have been recorded that
determines their 60 percent requirement
now if they're not in compliance we work
with the licensees to bring them back
into compliance and we certainly have
done that
very it monitored that very closely over
the last year
or more depending on
the significance of violations that have
been occurring so currently again we
only have one that is not meeting the
ratio
on uh the cigar bars um another point to
make uh
and it was brought up earlier in
reference to the pandemic the division
of enforcement has worked very closely
with the licensees not only during the
pandemic when when emergency orders were
in place but afterwards getting the uh
industry back up and running to where it
is now
in regards to revenue
over the course of the last four years
the cigar bar revenue has stayed pretty
flat
in
fact in 2020 we saw a slight increase
during the heat of the pandemic
to 14 632 dollars generated from the
cigar bar licenses
the specific issue regarding the tax
exemption
on the cigar bars
is
related to
statutes in the in
through dra
that exempt
premium cigars premium cigars through
their statutes are specifically
specifically
so is the premium cigar included in the
dollar sales numbers it is for our
thank you for your testimony and for
coming before the committee
the
the one
not to be named licensee that's out of
compliance uh by what degree are they
out of compliance
what degree um
i don't have the specific figures in in
front of me
he's asking he's answering the question
oh is it by a little bit or a lot
it it's around the 10 to 15 percent
so
10 to 15
we have three that are closely working
with uh the division of enforcement
right now in the licensing unit the in
the our auditing unit um that are
floating right around the sixty percent
so
would you believe that the intent of
cigar bars and giving them the license
to sell liquor was that it should not it
was is a is a service but it should not
actually
fundamentally affect their
business of selling
cigars and
pipe you know
pipes and whatever else they sell so
that if they were to lose their license
then they would just be a cigar
establishment which is what the original
that's what their business plan is
supposed to be
thank you very much
yes thank you chairman and yes i i
believe the original intent of the cigar
bar license was for retail cigar
locations to
have the privilege of selling a beverage
to their patronage as they enjoy their
cigar within their establishment
you know the
perspective that we have seen
over the last year or so
is that
new licensees who are struggling with
compliance issues are utilizing their
license for which it was not intended
and that by far
is the vast minority of the licensees
again there's 15 only one is currently
not in compliance
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you chairman
having no more cards i will close the
public hearing on
house bill
1237 and i do see the
sponsor for
91 is here
and so anybody who would like to testify
good morning representative leitchman
good morning mr chairman and first
before i start with my
prepared remarks i just want to thank
you for your courtesy in allowing the
sponsors to appear today versus last
wednesday
mr chairman and members of the commerce
committee
thank you for allowing me to testify in
hb 5091f and renames the division of
enforcement and licensing
to the division of education and
licensing
hb 1591 fn
contains similar language except for the
abolishment of the 20 liquor
investigators that appeared
in the house version of hb one and two
that's the budget bills last year
hb 50
1591 reclassifies the investigator
positions
to licensed specialists
the idea to eliminate the liquor
investigator positions within the liquor
commission
is due in large part to liquor
commission's disregard to years of
well-documented concerns
these concerns are from the office of
the legislative budget assistant lba
the joint legislative fiscal committee
the house finance committee
legislators and many others because the
division fails to reflect
its true roles and responsibilities
when created in its present form in 2009
the division was and i quote
to optimize profitability
maintain proper control
effectively and efficiently operate
and to provide service to customers
last year mr chairman
another audit of the enforcement
division presented to the fiscal
committee
again identified very troubling findings
many of these findings have been
identified
to the joint fiscal committee
in years past and remain unresolved
some are more than a decade old
the lack of transparency
and the willingness of the liquor
commission to provide requested
information as a regulated agency has
been well documented in this the latest
audit and previous audits i believe last
week we had all the audits delivered to
one of the roles of the joint
legislative fiscal committee is to
oversee and review financial and
performance audits of all state agencies
the latest performance audit
again february
of this last year which you should have
received last week
contains many disturbing behaviors by
the enforcement division
when the lba suggested increasing
oversight by the legislature
the liquor commission responded
we do not concur
for instance the commission has not
provided the agreed upon quarterly
reports detailing extra
judicial enforcement
jurisdictional enforcement i'm sorry
compromising transparency and ethical
behavior
the commission would rather provide
narratives rationalizing the
division's extra jurisdictional
activities such as this establishing of
sobriety checkpoints saturation patrols
or investigating motor vehicle
violations by investigators
the lba found and i quote
the division expanded its scope of
operation actively moving away from
regulation in licensees and permittees
and moving towards general policing of
the broader segment of society
the sponsors of hb 1591
believe the commission should focus on
its statutory obligations
legally delegated authority and leave
general policing and enforcement to such
law enforcement agencies such as the new
the lack of transparency in the behavior
of the liquor commission should concern
us all
since in this latest case the liquor
commission has again demonstrated for
more than another decade an
unwillingness to participate in the
oversight process
we are obligated to the citizens
of this state
to make essential changes on how the
liquor commission operates and i
did print out
my written testimony which i certainly
and i would be happy to take any
questions
any questions representative bartlett
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you representative liesman for coming to
speak to us because
this is an issue that kind of surprised
some of us um
and
when i look at the sponsors i'm
wondering
um
to me i don't know all of the members on
the fiscal committee but this is a
bipartisan bill can you tell me if all
of these sponsors are on the fiscal
committee
sure thanks for the question so
for those of you that don't know what
the joint legislative fiscal committee
is
it consists of five senators and five
house members and we generally meet
monthly
two of the sponsors of the bill
representative emerick and myself are on
the fiscal committee the rest of the
sponsors are on the finance committee
any other questions from
committee
none thank you very much thank you mr
chairman a pleasure to see you
pleasure to see you too
uh chair will call on
gerald griffin
who i believe is a
good morning
good morning mr chairman
and committee members
i am representative gerald griffin and
i'm here in support of hb 1591
eliminating the enforcement division of
the liquor commission
by way of background i serve as vice
chair finance one
i am also a co-sponsor on the bill
during last year's budget process all
funding for the division was eliminated
for fiscal 23.
the police duties of the division
duplicate those of local and state
police
this bill merely cleans up the
references to the vision as they
currently appear in our laws
and bring those brings those laws into
line
with the fiscal reality on the ground
the training division and all its
functions remain under this bill
the act
the action of finance one
was bipartisan
and a rare opportunity to save the state
money
with a minimum of consequences
most of the members of the enforcement
division are qualified police and have
been through training for police
and with the current employment
situation there are many opportunities
for them to remain in their chosen field
with either state or local police
the action of finance was in part driven
by recent audit reports of our liquor
operations
i joined the legislature in 2016
and during that term i got to read the
then current audit report
i was shocked at the deficiencies and
the amount of work that would be
required to fix them
i was even more shocked when i returned
to the legislature in 2020
to find a brand new audit report that
showed
little progress had been made
i ask that the committee join with us in
support of this bipartisan bill
um before you go just
humor me i guess is can you give me one
example of what you were really shocked
about that they have not addressed yet
you know it's it's been some time
since i read those reports
and i would really refer any committee
member
interested in
the deficiencies to read those reports
i don't want to
go off the top of my head i don't have
the report i thought maybe you had one
salient item that you could really say
boy
it was there in the old the first report
it was there in the second report why
can't they get this thing fixed i
understand but i refer you to the
reports i think you'll be shocked
thank you very much for your testimony
okay the chair will call up um
aiden moore and mark armageddon
from the liquor commission and needless
to say they are in opposition to the
bill
good morning gentlemen
good morning mr chairman committee
members
my name is aiden moore i'm the legal
coordinator for the state liquor
commission
prior to assuming this position
i became a member of the bureau of
enforcement and licensing in 1981
served in the liquor commission for 26
years
my last 10 were as the chief of that
unit
and i cannot tell you how strongly i am
opposed to this
bill some of the legislation and chief
armageddon will speak but i just want to
make make you aware that
some of the provisions of this bill
make
no
do not provide a pathway
to the elimination of these positions
and the proposed savings that are
supposed to come from
um if all of these people are going to
be eliminated
then there is going to be a projected
savings about two and a half million
dollars
but there's also
a
need to re-hire people
to serve
in a civilian capacity
plus the
legislature must pay the specialist for
two years under the personnel rules
as well as payouts which are going to be
approximately
over six hundred thousand dollars for
these people to leave
so
the savings is really not going to be
recognized
as it's
portrayed
and
with that i'll be happy to take any
questions on that but i would ask if
i know chief armiganian has quite a bit
thank you aiden
first of all for the record for those of
you that don't know me
uh my name is mark armagenian i'm the
director of division of lice
division of education licensing and
enforcement for the liquor commission
i've been asked to give you a little of
my background private previously to this
job
i've been here four years prior to that
the previous 28 years i was a commander
for the state police
and in several different capacities had
commands from
units to troops to bureaus to field
areas one of them being this building
and the troop area that covers the
capital area to include regulatory units
within the troop are within the state
police
um within my 34 years of law enforcement
i've been deemed and it's hard for me to
say because i am a humble person uh i'm
a fixer i'm a doer
and if you need something fixed
let's do it and that's what we did with
this division and i put five minutes
down on my card but it's going to take
me a little longer than that i will
provide some written documentation
to educate each and every one of you
thoroughly
on what this division has done in the
last four years the restructure of this
division the audit that happened
two months after i walked in the door
and didn't even have a chance to fix
anything and we'll talk about that also
um
you will hear a little bit those of you
that know me you'll hear a little bit
more directness than you've heard from
me in the past
because not only is this frustrating but
it's irritating this is a dangerous bill
it's dangerous to our communities it's
dangerous to the agency uh the uh
industry that it regulates and to be
quite frank it endangers the welfare of
our children in this state that we look
out for on a daily basis and if those of
those people that want to support this
bill
stick by their guns with it they are
literally flying in the face of what
i've just said
back in 2018
when we walked in and we restructured
this division
we changed the face of the command staff
there is not one command staff left for
those of you that have been around a
little while there's not one command
staff left
in
the command structure of this division
the back of the house our investigators
have been changed the demeanor has been
changed the mission has been redirected
with view with purpose and with mission
to at the end of the day
we're doing business better than i hate
to say
my one of my predecessors sitting next
to me but we're doing better than our
predecessors have done business
and i will tell you that we are
probably
i'd say three months away from being
kalia accredited
one of 18 accredited law enforcement
agencies in the state one of only two in
the country that are regulatory abc
alcohol beverage and control
we have achieved that mark through
audits
and through showing our policies and
procedures that we're doing everything
the way we should be doing at an ultra
high level
compared to the
the agencies that are in this state
that literally are perceived
as the pinnacle of law enforcement
whether federal or state
we are doing it better
because there is a vested interest in
doing it better
so if i could go through this
piece by piece i i have provided
or i will be providing
written documentation to break down for
each and every one of you
what has transpired in the last four
years
and it will give you a view of what
moving forward
what we're going to be doing in the
future
as i said in 2018 we restructured
we actually aligned our supervision to
have
one-on-one control over the
investigators and and auditors in the
field
not only did that give us
more accountability better
accountability but it made it more
efficient and more effective as we move
forward we went from a revenue footprint
18.3 million to today 19.5 million
because of oversight
we are generating revenue for the state
at the same time we have industry
supporting us because we have opened up
lines of communication that
have are
beyond what anybody would perceive and
believe would happen between a
regulatory agency and the people that
they regulate we have a bond a network
in a support group that you will hear
testimony from that support this
division
being in existence and having oversight
over their industry
they should be the first ones sitting at
the table saying we don't want it and
they're here
backing us why because when they call us
we answer the call when they have
questions
our customer service is is paramount
and it's beyond reproach
they call on the weekends we respond and
i will tell you that i know a lot of you
have reached out to me with different
questions over the years and and even in
this capacity i have not heard from one
sponsor on this bill
not one
except for when i sit in front of fiscal
and get told of stuff that happened 10
years ago
that i am not responsible for and when
reading the audit and everybody will
point out the audit but everybody misses
the second page of the executive summary
of that audit in in the seventh and
eighth paragraph buried
in that audit says that the current
administration is not responsible for
the shortfalls
and they are responsible for
implementing efficiencies and
effectiveness in their in their
beginning stages of course
we were just walking in the door when
this audit started
it was only published in 2021
or i'm sorry yes 2021
when actually
if you
look at what has been completed and what
has been presented
and i will follow up on this
representative because i don't know what
isn't making it to you
what has been presented
to fiscal
is that we are at walking in the door
when it was presented we were at 84
completed on 47 observations
we at this point are at 92 percent
completed
when you ask the auditors how long does
it take you to do 47 observations
they'll tell you five years
we did not do that in nine months
we did it because we were working on it
since 2018 and we're changing the way we
did business
why because you asked for it our
citizens asked for it the industry asked
for it and to be quite frank about it
that's the way we keep our kids safe in
this state is with oversight
so
when when i hear of
some of this stuff last week with the
jurisdictional uh
bill that was brought up and i hear
high-speed pursuits
and late night raids
i question where they come from and i
get the same answer
a constituent told me
i like to know who that person is
i like to know why sitting here is the
first time that i hear about stuff when
my phone number is available to
everybody
i will handle it if we do business wrong
but we're not
so
i'm kind by saying misinformation
because there are some fabrications that
are out there also and when i find out
about them i address them but at the end
of the day
i want you to be assured here
through our reporting to this committee
quarterly
on what might be
perceived as extra jurisdictional
they are life safety issues
and i will tell you that
in any other forum
in law enforcement
what is perceived as extra
jurisdictional life safety i'll give you
an example
down what used to be the store 24
down by uh um
duncan south main dunkin donuts thank
you
what ended up happening late night as
one of our investigators was driving
back to
our store street
headquarters he was behind a car
at that traffic light and the car went
through a cycle of lights
and the car wasn't moving so a stop was
initiated
he walked up to the car to see a woman
slumped over the wheel of the car she
was oding
he ends up calling rescue and local
police department to get people on board
and try to save that woman's life
at the end of the day
that's perceived as a extra
jurisdictional item
there are people there are law
enforcement officers throughout this
state that are praised
for
above and beyond
credit
for saving somebody's life and we are
sick
we are sitting before you
because we are criticized for life
safety issues
cars they have driven off the road while
we're going to
uh uh inspect one of our licenses set um
establishments when we do that
we are only doing that to check on a
life safety issue
state police headquarters is then called
and a trooper shows up for it
we are not doing extra jurisdictional
items we are doing things we are doing
the job within the purview of the
authority that this body has given us
that we report to constantly
quarterly
on extra jurisdictional items since two
so
what i also want i
want you to know is that
the this is an unfunded mandate toward
the local departments and municipalities
throughout the state
with the consistency of our unit
not being out there you will you will
take away number one the administrative
process so everybody is dealt with
infractions are dealt with by
misdemeanor or felony
not an administrative finding
of as most of you know
begins with
our
education platform
educating everybody
and moving up through
of course accountability
it's a progressive way of doing
accountability
not going for the jugular right off the
bat
we pro we we regulate this industry
to
a level of industry
and community safety we don't over uh
regulate it we don't under regulate it
after four years
education we have had 700 even through a
pandemic
or the nucleus of the pandemic because i
know we're still in it
724 events
in
we have reached out and educated and
touched
000 people in a population of one point
maybe three million
we've almost hit half of those in four
years educating them on the misuses of
alcohol
and holding the industry accountable
on the misuses of alcohol
at the end of the day
i can only say that our prevention
partners
who you will hear from do not support
this and we have a great relationship
with them
again
the industry that we regulate whether
grocers restaurant and lodging
and i know i'm going to forget somebody
at the end of the day
they support us the chiefs
support us
the sheriffs support us
the people in your communities
the parents in your communities support
what we're doing
if you hear
anything that doesn't make sense to you
please pick up the phone call mark and
ask me
there are fallacies out there there's
misrepresentations out there and at the
end of the day it gets pretty disgusting
that somebody has to go to those levels
to take shots at us
with that i apologize that i do have a
passion for this work
i didn't leave
state police because i was disgruntled
i saw an opportunity to change the way
business was done with with liquor
enforcement and we have done it
and with that in mind
um
i don't know was there a question asked
asked i'm sorry
okay uh with that in mind
i will take any questions
whether on this job or another job
okay representative bartlett has a
question
thanks very much mr chair and thanks for
coming and um
talking to us about these issues
um i think one of the things that we
have a tough time balancing is that
as a legislature we have a
responsibility
to look at the finances of every
division and the liquor commission
certainly is a revenue producing
division but it has expenses as well
um
i think that you would agree that it is
fair that there is an audit done on a
fairly regular basis of any
agency
but i also think that um
the timing
that as you point out is terribly
important that you had just come into
the the job
though it had been about six years since
the previous audit when you came in and
there were still
open items that you were trying to
address
if this bill were to pass or to be
amended
um
would it be fair and i'm i you know this
is going to go to subcommittee because
there's going to be lots more questions
about all of this but would it be fair
to extend
the passage of this bill for say two
years
that would have given you about six
to implement the changes that you wanted
to make
that would address some of the
enforcement
um and you know issues that came up by
audit
um we're trying
like i said we're trying to balance
our responsibility with what your
division does which is a very important
division not only to this agency i mean
to this committee
but certainly to the state absolutely
and thank you for your question and
great to see you representative um
i
i would respectfully just disagree with
that
for for a couple of reasons
um
number one
revenue wise
we
we operated on a 4.2 4.3
million dollar budget
in the division and generate just short
of 20 million dollars
that is done because of the men and
women women that are on the sworn side
of the house along with
the men and women that are on the
auditing side of the house
if we lose
those positions
though first of all you can't just
civilianize those positions of course as
you know and in those law enforcement
officers who
have bought into and and are educated in
a career field
just say okay i'm going to be a civilian
now they're going to stay in law
enforcement which was brought up it
definitely was brought up um
we have found that
the pandemic has actually in creating
positions which was brought up
has brought
employees
closer to us we're not a stepping stone
we're actually an agency that has people
within it that care about the work that
they're doing
i i can't help nor speak of some of the
shortfalls and some of the great things
that have been done in in the mid to
early 90s with with uh aiden's group
um
and and some of the shortfalls with with
some of my predecessors i can't speak of
that we do keep bringing that up i'm not
responsible for that i was a homicide
detective when that happened
um
working on some of the most egregious
crimes in the state
but i can tell you this
my my reputation precedes me
i'm not being arrogant by saying that
um i'm a fixer
and at this point i don't think we need
the six years because we're at 94
percent
of fixing those audit
observations now
and what has been left over is is
actually statutor
statutory change and rule change
i was asked quite
quite recently why
the policies of the division
have been left for the last
to be changed we've done the 700 rolls
we've done the 500 rules we've done
the the uh
1100 rules um
direct shipping
um
licensing auditing
the
the 600 rules are the rules that
actually govern
the enforcement the enforcement policies
thank you and
the 200 rules which govern our
administrative hearings
the reason why they were done in that
order is because every one of the
previous
rules stated
a series of rules actually directly
affects the 600 and 200 rules you'll
keep changing those two if you do it
that way but what we did do and i don't
want anybody to think because this will
be thrown out there the 600 rules
weren't done the 600 policies on
enforcement weren't done
the for those of you that were in the
military or or know
what we would call sops our policy
standard operating procedures
those were done when i walked through
the door we needed to do them they
needed to be updated they were terrible
they they needed
to have position they needed to have
purpose and they were done right off the
bat the problem with this the the audit
was just to be quite frank about it and
transparent
i was asked to do
a assessment
a 90-day assessment when i walked in the
door that 90 days turned into six months
really quick
i
by november of that year
i turned to the deputy and said oh my
gosh
there's so much here we need to stop we
need to document what we're doing we
need to start changing things it was
taking us too long
because we were tripping over rocks and
finding stuff underneath them that
wasn't obvious and and we started doing
it
i was naive
i will say this and i i
don't say this often i was naive to
think that the
great work that the men and women of
that division did in the four or three
years previous to the publication
of that audit
would have been earmarked in the audit
but all i was told was it's outside of
the audit period
so
i got two lines in the second to the
last in the last paragraph of the
executive summary that said i'm not
responsible for it and i've done some
stuff
that that's what i got out of it and
they pretty much and i i don't mean i
guess i am being facetious here
um my document that was given which was
a very brief document maybe 30 pages
from an ultra high level maybe a hundred
thousand foot level
um my face was shoved into my own
information said
what have you done in the last four
years
that's what i walked into
i took it
like i should but at the end of the day
we're at a point now where
we have answered in front of fiscal
quarter well at one point it was monthly
we've moved to quarterly
and and we report to you
in this committee quarterly and what is
perceived as extra there is total
transparency with what we do on a daily
basis
these documents are also posted on our
on our home page
as soon as you open it up
you'll see
what we're doing for
activity
and and
speaking of which and talking about
regulatory focus
through
from 2019 to 2021
the division has handled 42
calls for service and conducted
1937 criminal and administrative
investigations of liquor law violations
not
any of the other egregious crimes this
division is specialized we've been asked
to be specialized by the chiefs of
police
that are that that have oversight of the
jurisdictions that a lot of you have
oversight of or represent
the sheriff's departments
and and quite frankly
select persons and mayors throughout the
state
there there really is some of the things
that have been said from the past could
be very true they are not true
today in 2022
they are not true
period
and if anybody would like to speak to me
about that
please i leave my phone number totally
available to talk about but i have heard
from nothing
on on anything that has fallen short
other than this audit
did i answer your question
representative i'm sorry thanks very
much i i really i i think those of you
that
have known me from testifying here over
the last 15 years know that i i this
this is way under my skin right now
we get the feeling of that yes
representative
you thank you sir uh your your passion
um has certainly uh been uh recognized
in your remarks and also your
responses uh to the to the questions
that have been put to you
um
i'm trying to distill
the difference
between
you and the sponsors of the bill
as as i listen to everything that's
being said here and i'm wondering if
this would be an accurate assessment at
this point
apparently there's an audit
and the audit covered a period of time
which
predates
your
um
your leadership of of this division is
that correct and
and i'm i better continue otherwise
you're going to have to keep asking for
permission for follow-ups
so um so what i've heard you say is that
the
the deficiencies
and perhaps abuses or neglects or
whatever the problems that are
identified in that audit
for the for a prior period
have largely been addressed
and rectified
such that
it appears as though
the sponsors of the bill are either
unaware of this
or they just generally have a
philosophical difference as to how
things ought to be operated whether we
ought to have an enforcement division or
not
so
because i'm sorry that i that i've
wrapped up essentially three questions
in one but it has saved me from having
to continue to ask for permission
uh with the uh the second and third
part of the question so i made it abc
instead of one two three thank you
thank you representative it was
efficient um
i i can i i'm going to break it down if
i forget a part
uh first and foremost um i i don't i
won't speak
on behalf of the representative and and
it seems like division one
um fiscal division one um because um
i don't know i haven't spoken to them
the only person i had spoken to at the
time was uh
representative ober when i walked in the
door here
um
and uh and we had a great conversation
and it was left at that
and and i told her what my focus was i
will tell you that um
the audit period fiscal 1819
is within the time that i'm here
fiscal 18 i came in in
april april 6 to be exact of 2017 two
months before the the audit period so i
was learning names and processes and
going through my own assessment of the
division during the audit time
the deficiencies that they found and
they had the time to dig in the weeds
were the deficiencies that i found too
at a different level of course because
i'm not a full-time auditor i'm i have
to run a division and and and i had some
risk assessments to make really quick
um and we did that and we took on the
sworn part of
the division
primarily right out of the shoot because
that was our big biggest risk we had a
we had a law enforcement risk so
um and and a safety concern
so so we took it on it was the obvious
um
at the same time um as we move forward
yes
we're at 90
and and somebody can correct me here i
think we're at 90 between 92 and 94
completed
um
with with the audit uh findings um
so so with that in mind um yes your your
assessment is right other than it
sounded like i wasn't here for the audit
period but i i was it was when i was
to conclude so i understand
so in effect
you might be
understood to be saying in short
the solution that is being proposed for
cited deficiencies
is no longer uh needed
uh
because you
actually are at 94 percent with respect
to addressing the deficiencies that this
bill proposes to
remedy by
eliminating the enforcement division
that's thank you very much sir thank you
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
could you help me understand um
in house bill 2
is it true that
the uh
the line items for your division were
they removed in whole or in part
and if so how are you operating
uh going forward if
your division is not financed in
those positions were removed those light
line items were removed and they were
put placed back in again
so in the committee conference report
go ahead yes sir
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
what kind of arrests
does the liquor commission need to be
able to make that cannot be done by
state police at the request of and with
evidence provided by the liquor
commission after having obtained a
warrant by a judge and how many of these
arrests are made every year
so i don't have my arrest numbers um
if you civilianize
uh the division
there's there's statute that actually
um allows police officers to transfer
probable cause to each other
um
if they are not law enforcement officers
they are witnesses
like any other civilian
so at that point it hampers
the efficiency of an investigation
to the point where time as you know time
is of the essence in a lot of these
investigations and and we're not talking
small investigations
as you've seen on the news we're talking
death resulting
investigations
where the state police in state police
keeps being mentioned here
and believe me the state police is very
fond to me of course i spent my whole
state police and death resulting crashes
as they
relate to our licensed establishment
will defer to us
because the mindset is
we because we specialize
in
navigating through our licensed
establishments
they would rather have us do it
and ascertain documentation and and
evidence then them do it
follow just for clarification for the
question may include thank you so just
to clarify
by having sworn officers as part of the
liquor commission it is so for the
obtaining of evidence that could be used
in criminal prosecution as opposed to
eyewitness testimony
so so there's rules of evidence there's
chain of custody there's
okay
perfect thank you perfect thank you
representative
any other questions
uh see none thank you very much
uh so i uh dawned on me that these uh
reports were in our committee room from
last week
and uh everybody had already gone home
when i saw them so that's why they're
being distributed now
so you now have you now have the audits
that are being referred to
good quality reading
so everyone will have a chance to read
up on them before we do the subcommittee
next week
okay
um
chair will call on henry veyu of new
hampshire
lodging and restaurant association
good morning
mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is henry valu
and i'm here on behalf of the new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
um the association uh has taken a look
at the bill um and as i put down on
my card has some concerns uh with the
bill
and primarily in two parts
one part
is that at the end of the day
if something like this was done
what the industry wouldn't want to see
happen is that
uh
the enforcement rule
uh just uh be transferred from
the
plainclothes
enforcement folks at the
commission
to
uniform either state or local officers
we're a hospitality industry
and i think folks have a concern
with you know
the hospitality atmosphere of uniformed
uh enforcement folks
and that is not to say that the
state and local enforcement folks don't
do a good job at what they do
the
the uniformed uh officer in the back
chief goldstein does a great job uh for
franklin
but
again it's it's the it's the hospitality
atmosphere that we're trying to provide
and um and i would additionally say that
um
and i think uh uh chief farmer gaden
touched on it um
when there
are issues uh when maybe a licensee
felt that the approach
that the enforcement folks took that his
team took
um
i will say that mike summers who's
president association who's planning to
be here today but he couldn't um always
picks up the phone
uh and speaks uh with the chief
armageddon and it's nice to have
one
person really to reach out to
again
if the enforcement was then disbursed to
state and local
uh folks
there are a lot of other relationships
that i think mike would have to develop
to talk about maybe the approach
that
those officials were taking um so
i would say that they are uh responsive
uh where there have been
uh
you know instances where maybe the
approach of uh his team
uh wasn't right uh he he's been
responsive so um
those are basically the concerns we have
so if you were to move in this direction
uh i think just be cautious
because
at the end of the day you know
the devil we know is
we prefer that than the devil we don't
know
okay fair enough
any other no questions thank you very
much for your testimony
chair we'll call on uh dr terrella from
department of health and human services
shirelle
good morning
can you hear me
yes yeah you have to pull pull it pretty
close yeah
can you hear me now yes okay
thank you so much chair and the
committee members for the record my name
is dr sai charala i'm from the division
of public health i'm the bureau chief
for the population health i'm here
representing the department of health
and human services and we are in
opposition for this bill
just to give you the background
this bill has currently written will
have long term consequences for our
underage sale for tobacco
our underage use for tobacco alcohol and
liquor and it also will impact our
prevention and treatment resources for
our
for our mental health and substance use
so just to give you the background i
just want to start with numbers because
we love members
so
in new hampshire we have around 9 out of
10 smokers who start smoking at the
even before the age by age of 18. so
you're looking at the very younger age
for the start and once you have this and
especially now we have a vaping epidemic
going on in our state
um
for example in our 2019 uterus behavior
survey we have around 34 percent of our
high school students reporting that they
use uh vaping
when compared to the new u.s average
it's only 13 percent so we have a big
issue there
and in two years ago we have come to
this com this committee to talk about
increasing the age for the tobacco sales
by 21. so that's a big
thing that we have been talking about
so tobacco use not only have an impact
on the lung related illnesses especially
during this covet pandemic
but it also for youth it has um negative
health effects
they are also at risk of adverse brain
development because again with a
nicotine this has an addictive product
that has a direct impact on the
developing brains
so these are some of the issues and one
example i just want to think about from
a numbers perspective
tobacco or smoking causes smoking
related health care costs in new
hampshire specifically is
729 million per year so just imagine
that's the cost that we have to bear
and
when i'm looking at this one i have
couple of questions for the committee to
think about if the goal is to eliminate
the liquor enforcement or the
enforcement
group of this group
what's the plan for the replacement for
services provided by under this one one
is retail tobacco licensing
retail restaurant licensing for alcohol
and liquor underage sales and monitoring
for all products so alcohol tobacco
liquor and the most important is what's
the what is the plan for cynar
i'll go more detail about cyanar kind of
thing
basically sign our amendment requires
like all states and territories whoever
get the substance um
abuse and mental health service
administration money they have to enact
and enforce laws prohibiting tobacco
sales to minors
so basically
we in in new hampshire state received 13
million dollars as a block grant to
support our mental health and substance
use
and we
proportion a small portion work with our
mou with the dle to do that services
and
that actually would be impacted so if we
do not have a dle we would have to work
with our local enforcement local
our state enforcement and roughly we
have to pay almost close to uh 500 plus
thousand dollars to do that work on it
on a on a regular basis
so if you're thinking about some of
these things the most important piece is
this impact of this legislation is like
a lot of these services we would have to
depend on our state and local
departments to do that
and i'm more concerned about what kind
of an enforcement we would be seeing and
how that would impact long-term issues
our
underage health issues for our
really vulnerable population
so those are some of our talking points
and um i'm open to taking questions and
thank you are there any questions from
the community member we do have a
question representative abel
yeah
okay i've got it thank you uh thank you
so much for testifying uh let me be sure
that i that i heard you correctly
you're estimating or projecting that
your
department would spend four hundred
thousand dollars more
under this uh scenario if if um thank
you for the question um representative
what we are estimating is we have an mou
with the dle to provide the services
which is around 50 000
roughly which is a big investment from
our end but if we have to do with every
local city and think about that from
nashua manchester smaller towns so we
are estimating it to be close to 400 000
and this was 2020 estimates so
inflation so you're looking at close to
representative bartlett thanks very much
mr chair and thanks for coming and um
and pointing out an important issue of
what um liquor commission also enforces
um i think we kind of sometimes lose
track of the fact that the tobacco
related
incidents are also part of their their
enforcement so um
i guess i have to make that a question
would you believe i appreciate your
being here thank you so much
i appreciate that that input
right
uh so you know other questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
and i just want you to know that i would
not forget it because i'm the one who
actually
ran the subcommittee the legislation
to effectuate that the liquor commission
it was me
we'll go from smoking to liquor keep fry
good morning members of the committee
and i was going to say i care about both
and i'll be addressing both in my
testimony um
so uh a lot of what i was going to bring
up was already brought up so i won't
repeat it and i do have written
testimony so i will just highlight a few
things
again my name is kate friend the vice
president of advocacy at new futures
we're a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to work on health and
wellness issues we work extensively with
policy makers state agencies prevention
partners to reduce alcohol and other
drug problems in our state
we oppose 1591 which would eliminate the
enforcement authority of the new
hampshire liquor commission
as you know the the division has many
responsibilities but they include the
enforcement of the state's alcoholic
beverage laws and administrative code of
rule and providing education awareness
and outreach programming for licensing
um other law enforcement and public
groups and i just want to say that the
division is really part of new
hampshire's larger public health
infrastructure when it comes to
preventing young people from alcohol and
tobacco use
you hopefully will have a sign-in sheet
from the online blue sheet of prevention
organizations youth advocacy groups that
find the division of liquor enforcement
a really important partner in their work
working with young people and working on
preventing substance misuse in their in
their communities
um simply put if uh this bill were to go
into effect it would jeopardize the safe
operation of licensed vaping and alcohol
establishments and the division's
ability to protect vulnerable age
youth
dr sharala already spoke to the sinar
issue which would we would be very
concerned about the loss of
that funding would greatly impact
prevention treatment and recovery uh
funds to this state
so uh we don't take that lightly at all
um and i also just want to point out you
know tragically late last year we saw
firsthand what happens when liquor
establishes establishments decide to not
follow the law
the happy crab restaurant in salem new
hampshire served two teenagers
17 drinks while the bartender also
participated drinking along with them
and later that evening one of the
teenagers got behind the wheel and
crashed the vehicle almost killing
himself and all three passengers
the liquor commission moved quickly to
suspend the restaurant's license and
ongoing investigation
the enforcement of alcohol beverage
control laws is an important component
of a comprehensive program designed to
protect the public health and safety
fortunately we don't hear about these
type of um tragic accidents every day
but if you were to eliminate an
enforcement agency whose job is to
enforce those laws it would set the
state back and i'm
very sure that it would result in
devastating results
and then i just wanted to add a few
things while i completely respect the
sponsors who brought this bill forward i
also
all right we were also concerned about
the audit we have several concerns we do
we have been in touch with the liquor
commission
division enforcement on that um i think
our avenue is that we don't always feel
that the liquor commission division
enforcement goes far enough so we have
our own concerns but i would
wholeheartedly agree that we have been
able to have really frank conversations
we work very closely with the liquor
commission division enforcement um when
we have issues and then we hear about
them in the field we bring them to
mark's attention and right away we get
an answer of what may or may not have
happened and i think a perfect example
of how we work collaboratively was
tobacco 21 a few years ago where um the
state law was at 19 the federal law was
at 21 there was um
a struggle in enforcement because of
the the state law still being 19 and you
know we really worked through policy
issues with
that division and other tobacco-free new
hampshire partners and i think we ended
up with a great result so that is my
testimony and i will leave my written
thank you do we have any questions
i guess we're all set thank you okay
and you got one more card left nancy
vaughn from the american heart
association
good morning almost afternoon for the
record nancy vaughn government relations
director for the american heart
association in new hampshire um and i'm
coming before you in opposition to this
bill
i do have written testimony which i will
turn in um but i just wanted to um first
of all let people know because i really
haven't been in front of this group
talking on tobacco issues for a while
but the american heart association has
been involved for many decades on
tobacco control it is the
tobacco use is the number one
preventable
cause of death from heart disease and
stroke and
a preventable cause of heart disease
risk factors in in general
so this is a very important
part of
what the liquor commission does here in
new hampshire is is as
others before me
mentioned is the tobacco control issue
which they have responsibility for
working with tobacco retailers first of
all on educating them on the law
and that's really the predominant role
that they do play
if there are retailers who continue to
fall out of compliance with the federal
and state law on tobacco 21
then they have other resources
that they can implement to ensure they
eventually do go into compliance
without
the liquor commission
division of enforcement being able to
carry this out we also have concerns
that this would fall on local law
enforcement authorities and for the same
reasons others have given this is not an
ideal situation for dealing with
underage tobacco use again we want the
the responsibility to remain
predominantly on the retailers complying
with the law and not selling to
underaged
buyers
but if
if this is
carried out mainly at the local level we
do have concerns
that youth will be the target of these
enforcement issues and this is a group
that is purposefully being marketed to
with these tobacco products kids are
getting hooked on nicotine in both
traditional cigarette product tobacco
products as well as electronic
cigarettes so we do not want to see them
further punished with
monetary fees and fines that could come
down on them from the local level if
caught with these products we really
again it's the retailers that we want to
see worked with um on complying with the
law
so again i do have written testimony but
if you have any questions at this point
on our involvement so if i understand
your testimony correctly that if we were
to pass this legislation we would
probably have to revisit the tobacco
statutes
and figure out who's now going to
enforce all these things
yes thank you very much for bringing
that um that up representative hunt
126k is the youth access law it is not
mentioned in the the language of this
bill at all um but it it has many
provisions within 126k that address
youth tobacco use
and again it is the liquor commission
division enforcement that that carries
those out we
as an organization would like actually
to see work done on 126k to remove the
penalties for youth
if caught with tobacco products
i don't know if that is a
a
possibility with this bill
but it is something that we would like
to see
but we do want to protect 126k because
it is the only enforcement that we have
to protect youth from tobacco products
fair enough
any other questions thank you very much
for your testimony
thank you very much having no more cards
um we have two blue we have um
blue online uh which
has shows three people in support 20
opposed
and most of them are people of the
members of the public but i do see in
opposition is the new hampshire
municipal association
the american cancer society cancer
action network and breathe new hampshire
so clearly
smoking gun is behind this issue
uh and 1591 also so on the blue sheets
signed up today we have uh four people
in support um joe griffin ken weiler
peter leishman
and bill hatch
in opposition we have uh vanessa shaheen
mark emma garden
uh daniel danielle
ellison and matthew
culver both of the liquor all three of
the liquor commission
and elizabeth smart uh sergeant excuse
me
uh the new hampshire association of
chiefs of police is in opposition
and
david uh goldstein from
[Music]
not sure but he's in opposition and then
uh representative david lowe is also in
opposition and with that we'll close the
public hearing in 1591 and yes we'll be
okay and otherwise we are adjourned to
lunch
oh
you know i mean something that's uh
you know
it was it's helpful to hear from you and
others
so here we're thinking it's been
received
you
so
sorry i gotta i gotta forget i don't
zoom i always gotta take my mics on i
don't remember anything my mic gone
you may proceed yep put your agreement
you're on
thank you so much mr chairman members of
the committee my name is rebecca
mcwilliams i'm a representative for the
west side of concord so you are
i'm here to introduce bill 1523
and this is not set in stone this is
really what i consider to be a draft to
start a conversation with the members of
the committee about solving a problem
that
i believe has been a long time coming
and is certainly ongoing
so just by way of background
i am a mom of three kids under the age
of five
i have four-year-old twins who are
currently in a daycare actually right
now they're in daycare um and i have a
one-year-old who is staying at home with
my husband
um and if we could find adequate care
for her he would be able to go back to
the workforce but like so many stories
i'm sure you have heard across the state
of new hampshire we have a lot of
caregivers for younger kids who have
been sidelined due to covid and lack of
quality daycare facilities
who are not able to participate in the
workforce because they have to stay home
and take care of children
this also happens to grandparents of
course we've just got people across the
state who are out of the workforce
caring for kids
and so it's a it's a nut that needs to
be cracked it's an ongoing problem we
had this issue pre-covered but i think
covid we could all agree has exacerbated
this significantly
we've had quite a few daycares that have
closed because of covid and don't look
like they're coming back online anytime
soon but
with a little bit of help and support i
think there's opportunity for us to
solve this problem and hence the bill
the goal here is to create
a revolving new hampshire child care
fund
so speaking in really broad terms what
this bill does is it creates a fund
that's meant to be revolving and
collecting interest and getting money
back year after year so it's not just a
one-time thing
approximately half of the fund would be
dedicated to supporting
facility needs so if you would like to
open up a new daycare and you need to
renovate a building and you'd like to
take out a loan to do those renovation
project tasks this fund could help you
with a loan
if you're looking to
buy or purchase a new facility same
thing it's a potential supplementary
source of income for not income
supplement
supplementary source of funds for you to
start up a child care facility and often
i've heard this in other committees and
in other discussions about child care in
the legislature often what i hear from
people across the state is that the bar
to starting a child care is significant
because you need to come up with your
own funds in order to open
and oftentimes that's too much for one
person or even a small business to take
on and so instead they decide to go into
a different field
i think that that's kind of been
pervasive over the years that people who
are qualified otherwise choose another
field because they can't get access to
capital so this fund would solve the
access to capital issue in the form of
loans and collecting some interest on
those loans would allow the funds to
regenerate and continue going
the second half of the fund
is intended to help the situation i
described earlier we have caregivers who
have been sidelined and are unable to
participate in the workforce because
right now they are caring for children
who are not yet old enough to go to
public school
and so
these otherwise completely eligible to
work adults have been taken out of the
workforce and if they could have help
either finding supplementary tuition or
overall tuition
or of course we're talking about
creating new child care facilities with
the second half of the fund then we
would be regenerating replenishing the
industry of child care in new hampshire
with which right now is in dire straits
so
that's kind of the overall background as
to what we're talking about with this
revolving child care fund bill
obviously i've made some assumptions in
the draft and i certainly would be happy
to
participate in a working group to talk
about some changes to this
right now i have this fund flowing
through the department of health and
human services
which as i understand has not
administered this kind of fund before so
there would need to be some expertise
key hires
accounting bookkeeping and even
following new hampshire banking law so
those are new roles that would have to
be created in dhhs in order to
administer the fund if it were
determined that the fund should live
under dhhs which is an assumption right
now in the draft of the bill
really i think the goal here is to set
up a bucket right so we want to have a
place for funds to go
and obviously i mean i'll say it out
loud obviously this is preemptive
expecting that we will be receiving some
federal funds
at which time the buildback better act
passes specifically dedicated to child
care so the anticipation is the funds
are coming let's set up a bucket to
receive those funds and i know this is a
little bit complicated because i don't
want to actually hire accountant
bookkeeper
minded folks to manage the fund if the
fund has not been funded that would be a
waste of taxpayer dollars or in this
case that would be a waste of any
dollars that came into the fund before
it was ready to actually be used
but at such time that the fund is funded
that would be when i'd want to pull the
trigger and actually hire the experts to
manage the fund so it's a little bit of
a chicken and egg problem but i don't
want to waste money about it
so i think we probably would need to do
some tweaks on how the timing works
let's just say build back better act
sends us 200 million dollars to new
hampshire
for child care we have the fund ready to
go within 90 days of receipt of federal
funding then we hire experts to address
that so it's something that this bill is
silent on but i think it could be worked
out
and then finally
just want to note note that there is a
fiscal note on here from the department
obviously they have some concerns about
personnel and cost and it's
indeterminate as to what the cost would
be and i think that's fair because
depending on the size of the portfolio
you know if we're talking about several
hundred million dollars that probably is
two to four positions
but if the dollar value is less than
that it may only be one position it
really depends on what we're managing
here so it's indeterminate because we
don't even know the scope
but just anecdotally i will tell you
that as the legislature we have an
opportunity to step up and create this
bucket to receive funds and if we don't
do this if the funds show up and go into
our general fund then we lose out on the
opportunity to really target them to
solve the underlying problem which is we
have a real real issue with the child
care business in new hampshire losing
facilities not being able to start a
facility and parents who otherwise could
work but are stuck home with their kids
because they can't find quality child
care so with that i'm happy to take
questions on the bill
okay
do you see some questions representative
bartlett
thanks very much mr chair and thanks for
coming to see us with this great idea
representative williams full disclosure
i'm president of the board of the
merrimack valley daycare center
we struggle with this issue year after
year after year
um what this
a couple of things would you be willing
to
consider an amendment to make this a
study committee because you're right
this is a very complicated issue
um and there are
a lot of considerations to be addressed
but the other part of that's not in here
and i'm wondering if you're considering
this is staffing is huge
that's one of the things that
many daycare centers struggle with
week to week not even just month to
month because they can many child care
workers can make more money at dunkin
donuts or walmart than they can taking
care of our children
um because this is not a priority for
our society
um would you be willing to amend this so
that we could look at this in a whole
um you know
and the other part of this is that the
child care
education programs have been
eliminated in the budget over the last
five years for our university system
three-part question okay we've got study
committee staffing and the pipeline all
right let's start with study committee
obviously i would like to get the whole
apple but if this needs to become a
study committee i'm willing to work with
this committee and do a study committee
this fall i would be open to that my
preference would be to try to resolve
some of these things a little bit
earlier through a working committee if
in in terms
of paying workers as part of the fund
i think that when i say that tuition is
the second half of the fund
tuition includes wages for staff at a
daycare facility
so i don't know that it needs to be
broken out further as wages versus just
saying it's meant to be tuition
assistance for
children whose caregivers otherwise
would be working
so i think it's a little squishy but we
could talk about it in a work session um
i think that when you start to get into
the weeds about what a fund can and
cannot be spent on there's winners and
losers and i think tuition kind of keeps
it more of a general
i would say that in
in a broad stroke
tuition for child care in new hampshire
has actually gone up pretty
significantly in the last two years
and i'm just speaking from personal
experience since my four-year-olds have
been in a child care facility for the
last three years
the the dollar value has gone up um
almost 500 a month so that that's a lot
for for a family that may have one
working parent and one not working
parent it's just it's a lot
um
so so i think i'm open to a conversation
about applying tuition dollars or how
the tuition is determined
um but i you know i i think that wages
is certainly one of the issues that
we've looked at in child care we've
tried to crunch this many different ways
you're absolutely right to say that you
can make more money working at dunkin
donuts at the window than you can
working at a child care facility and
honestly that is really sad for the
future of child care because we have
graduates workforce coming out of high
school who may be really interested in
working with kids but they know they can
make more money at a retail job and it
may not just be dunkin donuts it could
be anything in retail
and not saying that we don't need people
working retail jobs in new hampshire but
when someone is sidelined immediately
after graduation they have a passion for
kids they may have already been a
babysitter and gotten cpr certified you
know they're halfway there
and then they decide well this isn't the
future for me because there's no money
in it then we just end up with this
ongoing cycle of we can't find people to
work at care facilities because they've
already decided that it's not the
business for them to be in for a
long-term career
so certainly pipeline is a concern i
know we had some programs probably 10 or
12 years ago as part of high school
to allow students to get their
certificate at a technical college in
order to immediately become a daycare
worker and manage a class full-time my
understanding is that those programs got
unfunded
that you can't do that anymore so you
would have to go out on your own and
spend your own dollars to get your
certificate either online or taking some
classes
in person
that i think that creates a barrier to
entry
certainly if we're able to do this with
other apprenticeship and trade programs
for construction i don't know why we
shouldn't be able to do this for child
care because
there's a huge need in new hampshire and
representative weston
thank you
and thank you uh representative williams
for bringing this to us
i am
i like the idea of having something some
structure already in place in case this
money does come through we don't want to
wait too long and
not use not have the
facility set up
i am curious why you've chosen dhhs to
manage this
and my understanding was that in the
past there was a child care fund managed
through the new hampshire community loan
fund and i'm wondering why you wouldn't
use that same structure
great question
so the new hampshire community loan fund
did administer some funds for child care
tuition through the late 1990s
and then they ran out of money so it
basically just dissolved and went into
the community loan funds general fund
so there to my understanding there is
not a focus right now at the new
hampshire community loan fund related to
child care
and tuition for child care
i think that it's great to have a
non-profit that can be focused on
something like this
but i don't believe that all of the
funds that we're expecting to receive
from the fed would need to go to a
non-profit to be administered
because they would have to go through
the request for proposal process right
so they would be submitting a proposal
competing with other non-profits to
administer a fund and then if they are
awarded or multiple non-profits are
awarded this
rfp
then they would receive a slice of the
pizza say a sixteenth of the slice of
the pizza
and i really want the whole pizza to be
administered in one place so
while a non-profit managing small
dollars may make sense
i think it it's
wiser over the course of how this will
play out
to keep an extra administrative hurdle
out of it and also for the dollars we're
talking about to make sure that it's
managed in one place
thank you
i think
this has to go to some sort of study
committee i mean
i can think of a
a lot of things that need to be firm
uh before it becomes legislation and uh
um
uh i mean if if the if if you could make
a profit
uh
on taking care of these kids
believe me
this wouldn't be happening we wouldn't
be having this conversation
so obviously that's not the case
which means that the federal government
is going to have to get involved
how you exactly do that needs to be
figured out
and how you
you know and you've gone through uh some
scenarios which makes sense to me
but it just needs to be hammered out i
mean there are just
it's it's it's going to be a government
program
period be otherwise it's not going to
happen so uh
the private sector cannot and will not
invest enough money so
uh and and
any kindergarten that would survive is
there a question
here uh
so i think that in order to get uh
support
it would be my recommendation i think
that you it's not a question that's an
opinion if you go to a study committee
scenario
i think um
you might get somewhere which is what i
don't know how to ask the question would
you believe he thinks he needs to study
would you believe what do you think we
need to go to study on this yeah i
believe you need to go to a study
committee would you believe to that we
this is why i don't make a lot of
speeches
representative bartlett thank you very
i was just wondering if you had a chance
to run this by the
new hampshire council for child advocacy
i have not no
i think that they could be
i think you'd find that they'd be very
helpful
representative perez thank you
do you believe that
if we pass this bill we can utilize
some of the uh other industries that are
already using um
colleges
and trade schools like bai system for
example you know they have some programs
that they train people
and they already have a job lined up
after they finish the 15 weeks of
training do you believe that this bill
ideas from other programs and we can
have more people train and quickly make
our time and then have day cares or
providers they can have jobs lined up
for the people who's getting this type
of training
i think providing training is always a
good idea
i think the challenge that we are
running into right now in new hampshire
is wages
and perhaps there could be a bonus
related to completing training in order
to incentivize
but to get people to attend that
training they have to be able to see the
cherry or the apple or whatever they're
chasing
and so right now i think it's become
a less wanted industry
by people who are entering the workforce
because they don't see that cherry
at the end if they were to go through
the training is it really going to be
worth it for me and my family when i
start making money and so
training is great i think
creating an easy way to get training
especially as part of a high school
curriculum is awesome but there also
needs to be something a little bit more
in order to make it something people are
representative mcaleer
yes thank you for uh for coming today
just a question here you're talking
about
uh providing financing and investment
services do you do you see
that the folks controlling this um
basically
hire outside fund uh advisors investors
investment firms
are you doing it yourself
you know i think it really depends on
the value of the fund right
it depends on the value of the fund
right if we're talking about hundreds of
millions of dollars it may make sense to
bring in outside investors so that some
of that fun that's set aside can collect
interest
in good investments
but if the size of the fund was only say
you know 10 to 25 million
probably wouldn't be bringing in outside
investors for something somewhat smaller
right thank you sure
representative greeson
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for presenting the bill
answering our questions
you mentioned earlier that it costs too
much to open a business and yet there's
this tremendous demand a need for child
so what are the obstacles to these
businesses private businesses being able
to open have you looked at regulations
statutes current statutes now that might
be hindering
a private business from opening and why
is it the state's responsibility to take
care of your child's care needs okay
let's start with the hindrances to to
business
generally what we're looking at is
someone who wants to start a daycare and
they want to open up a facility so they
need to either buy a buy a building or
lease a space usually they're going to
lease a space as a step in the right
direction so they're going to need to
get a business loan
often and this is true across any
business in new hampshire often the
issues with getting a business loan are
debt to income right when we're looking
at somebody who wants to start a daycare
facility they may already have
significant credit card debt and so the
bank will say i'm really sorry but you
just have too much debt we can't take a
chance on you with a business loan
one of the other things we run into is
someone who has already failed doing
some other business and so the bank will
say well it looks like you defaulted on
a previous loan and so we're not willing
to give this to you again
folks who this is broad swath and not
meant to mean everyone but as a as a
general folks folks who want to start a
daycare facility in new hampshire are
not in it for the money and they tend
not to have the money behind the
business startup in order to show oh hey
i own my house so you could use my you
could use my home as collateral for this
loan we're talking about someone who may
already be renting and doesn't have a
lot of cash saved up to say that they're
putting in a certain percentage to start
the business so they don't look like a
good bet to a typical private bank
but that doesn't mean they don't love
children and wouldn't be good at it it
just means that when you look at them on
paper they're not a good bet for a
private bank and that's typically when
we're asking the state or in this case
the fed through the state to step in and
to support something that we need as a
service for the state
because we're seeing an awful lot of
caregivers who can't work right now due
to lack of daycare facilities that
sideline the economy
we have way more people hiring than we
have jobs right now as a general rule in
new hampshire and i hope that we can
come up with some solutions to shake out
more of those employees to work i think
providing opportunity for daycare
businesses to start would then provide
more care providers and free up some of
these people to work in the jobs
so your second question was why is it
the state's responsibility to provide
care for kids
and i would say in general it's the
state's responsibility to provide an
education for all of the children in new
hampshire we've already committed to do
that through our public schools and
we're extending that through vouchers
however people choose to learn so we've
committed as a state to provide funding
to children's education
we're already there
now we're talking about the children
under the age of five who are not yet in
kindergarten but we know as a state that
this is causing us serious problems with
our economy and our workforce and so we
decide yes also educating younger
children makes sense and we're willing
oh we do have representative
just a quick question have you uh talked
to the bia regarding this um proposed
legislation business and industry
association i have not yet but i look
forward to it okay great thanks
okay yeah thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
i have one other card here from uh
department of health and human services
karen
and chairman members of the commerce and
consumer affairs committee my name is
john williams and i am the legislative
director for healthy moon services it is
a pleasure to appear before your
committee i don't come here very often
but i always have a wonderful time with
in working with your chair and we'll get
you everywhere
so and with me today is i'll have her
introduce herself good afternoon my name
is karen hebert i am the director for
the division of economic and housing
stability for the department
and i just want to start off on a couple
of this high level point
i would like to start off on a couple of
high level points
and i do want to thank the committee and
also the bill's sponsor representative
mick williams and her willingness to
examine the issues and looking at other
approaches perhaps accomplishing her
goal it's very clear that the department
of health and human services is not a
financial institution we are not an
investment institution and for us to
comply with the request here with no
state fund or general fund appropriation
to stand up the program
we lack the expertise to do the kind of
thoughtful work that needs to be done
with a bill like this so i have to say
representative weston i did not know of
the new hampshire community loan fund
but perhaps that's something that could
be looked at as a similar kind of
approach to appropriately
managing these funds whether the
investment that the money might be
received by the department is one dollar
or a billion dollars it still requires
us to comply with all banking laws and
regulations as any other financial
institution or investment institution we
do a good job in the works that we do in
serving the citizens of new hampshire
to making them healthier
to have them grant independence but
we're not an investment institution so
again i just wanted to thank the sponsor
and her willingness to re-examine the
assumption of placing this
responsibility on our agency i would
like to ask
our director
ms hebert if she would provide
commentary to the committee
from her review of the legislation
thank you
so i also want to give representative
mick williams a great amount of credit
any efforts or ideas to improve the
child care industry are always worth
examining
so i'm really appreciative that she's
able to bring that forward
there is the potential of some
duplicity in the bill
where it does seek to establish
resources for child care providers
including startups so these resources do
exist in new hampshire as you may know
such as the community development
finance authority and the community loan
fund which as i understand will offer
services including tax credits loans and
there is also
maybe helpful to know the
ongoing efforts that are being made by
the department currently
with respect to federal funding that the
bureau of child development and head
start collaboration has been
distributing
it's approximately over 142 million
dollars in the last year as a result of
the various coveted funding streams that
we've received and we're really making
efforts to distribute that funding to
support the child care industry there's
a lot of work left to be done and i
think that while this is certainly an
idea we want to make sure that it is not
duplicative of certain efforts that are
currently being made by the department
with some of this federal funding and
that includes stabilization dollars over
a 49
million dollars that's been distributed
there are over 800 providers across the
state
um
615 of them
have taken advantage of this funding
resource to help stabilize their
programs
it doesn't answer everything but indeed
it is hoping to make a particular dent
in that process
so
there is also
an additional discretionary fund from
the american rescue plan dollars and the
amount of 29 million dollars that we're
trying to
uh and working with our stakeholders to
try to identify what are the priorities
that would be
that money would be useful for and we're
really narrowing that down to a number
of workforce initiatives
provider
assistance and family support
those initiatives are being
and currently there are initiatives
going on
to expand or really pilot programs right
now to try to test the expansion
for individuals who may be eligible for
the child care what's known as the child
care scholarship program it's child care
assistance
and what we want to be able to do is
test the expansion of
income eligibility for this it's paid
for through the child care development
fund which is a federal funding stream
and if we're able to
be successful in some of these pilot
programs
we want to be able to
bring that into the agency budget in the
future and hopefully be able to serve
many more parents than what are
currently able to
uh to utilize in or to be eligible for
that particular funding
there are a couple of other ish
initiatives that are ongoing as well
with respect to raising non-traditional
raising uh rates uh state payment rates
for providers providing non-traditional
hours
and continuing to provide employer
support for child care
all in response to what's known as the
cliff effect so these are there's a lot
in the industry that
it's a
complex industry
and also complicated by a number of
influencing factors one of them for
example is the cliff effect which is for
individuals who may be receiving public
assistance who
by way of acquiring employment
which increases their income
leaves them no longer eligible for
public assistance yet the difference is
such that
they fall off the cliff essentially
where the the income that they're now
making
is not what they were making while they
were on public assistance benefits
so there's
trying to find ways we can incentivize
making
making that easier for people so they
don't fall off that cliff so we can try
to engage with people who are receiving
public assistance so that they can
are there any
questions you want to keep going so yes
chairman i just wanted for clarification
on page three starting on lines nine
through 10.
the bill does currently is drafted make
clear that the funds would be separate
from the child care scholarship program
i just out of fairness to the bill's
sponsor that the commentary by director
hebert was meant to elaborate on those
efforts we're making around the child
care scholarship and i just wanted to as
a point of reference bring that to the
committee's attention that the bill was
representative hubert
does
there's a federal program called the aid
to
families i forget what it's called it
used to be called the um yeah a2
families with dependent children afdc
which has been replaced by tanf
temporary assistance for needy families
is that what you're referring to
yes is that an area that
a funding area that might be available
i could certainly look into that further
but i don't believe so because of the
regulations around federal funding
that would be for this particular
purpose tanf funding has specific
purposes
that have to be met for the use of that
funding
okay
any other questions seeing any get off
uh so the blue sheets
uh representative megan murray
uh representative maria perez and
representative williams are in support
uh
online there was 61 people for it and
four post
and with that i will close
the public hearing
and this will be scheduled for our
subcommittee
okay
oh
um
is
uh
essentially
is
straightforward
yes
cameras
is
um
i'm somewhat waiting for the sponsor
because he has another hearing
on this bill he's the only one on it you
all right so what are we doing for time
here so listen we just started this
we have mental health parody the 245 so
nice
yes
tommy hilfiger has a boat
it's a huge huge yacht
and he was parked out in front of one of
the hotels we were staying at
and every day you see they get out they
get a pump they have this big water
slide
it's like a two-story water slide
life's tough for you you're really that
waiting to speak at 1 45 and
so i certainly apologize for my
tardiness
no problem okay thank you and uh mr
chairman through you
to my esteemed colleagues um of the
general court my name is bill boyd
and i represent
district 21 in hillsborough town of
merrimack i come to you today before
before you
to present house bill 1589 which
prohibits a sale of products
containing intentionally added pfas
the language that you have before you on
the bill is modeled after maine's law
which was recently
passed within the last year
the key components to this bill are
two-fold it's phasing out rugged fabric
treatments by 2024
and it includes another phase of other
phos laden products phased out by 2030.
as i know many of you are
aware of
the issues and the challenges that my
community of merrimack has experienced
regarding pfas
i know that all of you are aware from
from reading stories in the paper about
the long-term impacts that pfos have
on people especially the way that it
impacts bodies the way that it impacts
fetal development but even more so
how this chemical has impacted my
community of merrimack but the
communities of londonderry
litchfield amherst in the communities
that surround the pease air force base
as a consequence forever chemicals have
become
a
permanent fixture in our life and
subsequently
with pfas comes a long shelf life
that has far-reaching impacts as it
relates to
not only our natural resources
but on our public health
many of you
we're given commissioner scott's letter
um to the committee regarding
the
cost of
of of what it would cost to enact the
law and begin the process
of of how we would phase out
these pfas products and i certainly want
to
want to thank
des for putting that together because
what i am proposing
is significant
and while the timeline is ambitious it
certainly
is is an element of concern that he has
and expressed in his letter out of of
all the pfos bills that i've raised this
year can actually say this is a letter
where i didn't see the word opposed he
actually said concerned and i'm very
grateful for the commissioner for
amplifying that kind of language
i i would suggest to you
that
um
the cost concerns are certainly
legitimate i don't i don't dismiss that
but if we're going to move forward
on creating
a program within des
that
puts down the foundation and hires an
individual to create the mechanics as to
how we're going to evaluate
and restrict these types of pfas
products in new hampshire
there's going to have to be a there's
going to have to be a level of funding
and we're going to need an individual to
provide a level of of data collection
that would be necessary
um and what i would also argue is is a
very mission critical first step
for
uh
should the law be signed should should
the bill be signed and passed and be
signed into law
would certainly be a necessary first
step forward to be
successful we don't want to be
asking
companies that do this sort of thing to
go through a process and not have not
have the
foundation to to provide that support to
back it up
new hampshire has a unique opportunity
to be a leader in minimizing the effects
on pfas by eliminating and reducing pfas
in both household and commercial sources
and the products are numerous
uh microwave popcorn bags dental dental
floss
uh things that the
items that we take for granted our daily
basis you know once we're done with them
and once we use them they get discarded
and the consequence consequently when
they're discarded generally ends up in
our landfills so
from my standpoint it's it's it's
important to realize
that there are certain landfills in new
hampshire that do have pfos sitting
sitting underneath the cap and some of
those landfills are beginning to to
leach out into our groundwater into our
surface water so i would i would suggest
to all of you that if by imposing this
type of
restriction on phospholadine products
we're actually going to be
protecting
the new generations of landfills that
the state regretfully is going to have
to be dealing with over the next couple
years as we as we move forward
so what i would say to you is that i
certainly would urge passage
of house bill 1589
but i i am flexible because
this is something brand new
i know maine kind of
went out on their own kind of like a
brave new world kind of thing they they
jumped into the bathtub without checking
the temperature to see whether it was
hot water or cold water they just
decided to do it
i certainly would embrace any
uh suggestions legislatively or from d
from des as to what would be
should you not agree with my agree with
the law that i'm proposing what would be
a reasonable and systemic process to
address these specific pro
pfas products
that could have a long lasting
impact
not just on on public health but also on
the landfills that these products do
fill so
i certainly want to thank through you mr
chairman to my esteemed colleagues again
of the general corey thank you very much
for your time and attention um and again
i certainly do apologize again for my
tardiness
and if anybody has any questions i would
be gracious to answer them thank you
today any questions
yes representative burroughs
thank you mr chair chairman and thank
you for being here and taking my
question which is
who if any stakeholders did you involve
in when you put this bill together which
i i understand is clearly modeled on on
what maine has done candidly no one me
i um i actually have a good friend that
lives in maine
that is has a professional relationship
with the
main sponsor uh senator rick bennett out
of oxford and uh i i had a conversation
with him about
his goals and his intentions and
you know i'm a new i'm a newly elected
state representative so it's probably
full hearty to
not go out and embrace um the agency
that would be impacted and certainly
you know my legislative colleagues on
both sides of the aisle so if anybody's
offended i certainly do i certainly do
apologize but i wanted to
at least begin the conversation
that
this is potentially a problem that new
hampshire is going to have to address
and i would rather be proactive and put
it on everybody's radar than to
wondering why we didn't address it and
we're reacting to a problem
but i thank you for the question it's a
fair one thank you
yes representative
thank you representative
floyd good afternoon how are you good
thank you good to see you good to see
you i want to thank you for bringing
forward this legislation i think it's
very important uh this might be a
question for des but um the amount of
money that it would cost to fund an
individual to you know to manage this
could you see maybe this money coming
privately from
so
just a a quick pivot i serve on the um i
serve on the new hampshire drinking
water and groundwater advisory
commission
commission was tasked with
investing 250 some odd million dollars
from the mtbe settlement fund to address
four specific water issues impacting
infrastructure
source water development source water
protection in in water quality and for
the last for the last four and a half
years that i've been on the commission
we've done so we've done some amazing
amazing work with that money
so
using that as analogous to what we're
talking about now i think there's a
unique opportunity to create some type
of a trust fund or an endowment to begin
to tackle these particular issues
and again it's again as i alluded to
previously it's going to take it's going
to take a certain amount of capital to
start the to start a program like this
up to manage what we're what we're you
know what we're seeking to do and i
would think
that
um
as
companies if if the law does get enacted
it means companies are gonna have to
pivot to different technologies and
they're gonna have to phase out what
they're using then yeah i think there's
a unique opportunity
for for for private contributions to
contribute to an endowment
and you know again not the not that
we're fans of studies or commissions or
anything to that effect but an endowment
i think could have a far
more reaching impact on tackling this
issue knowing full well that there's you
know there's this private there's a
private corpus that's being used to
interact with municipalities that may be
impacted by this and having as you know
not to be cliche but to have a
far-reaching impact in in remediating
the problem so i yeah i would say
coming full circle yes i i think that
would be an interesting solution whether
or not it's
it's feasible and palatable is is a
different story but i agree with you
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair and thanks for coming
on before our committee with this um
issue right here
i'm sorry i apologize it's okay
um
my question is that you were um were
basing this on legislation legislation
that passed in the state of maine
correct another very small state correct
when is it effective in that state and
it's already effective now it's
effective now and has and what is the
impact of nationally produced products
and their distribution to the state of
maine it's a good question i don't have
an answer i'd be more than happy to
reach out to my resources and get you an
answer to that
what i can tell you
is what what maine did went global the
guardian picked it up
wall street journal picked it up because
it is legitimately the first ban
on pfas products worldwide
first legitimate ban on pfas products so
it it got global it got global coverage
it's it's it's very popular
um the the legislation is popular over
in europe europe being um
i think a little bit more savvy um and
obviously you know which each individual
you know this there's a cultural
component to all the individual
countries in europe so i think they they
get they get the the long term impacts
of that but as far as the immediate
impact to the state of maine i'm not
privy but i'd be more than happy to to
research that foiling circle back that
would be great thank you representative
for the question thanks very much um
and another question i've got is
so
it's a great question
the timeline and again i want to amplify
the letter that commissioner scott wrote
regarding the the aggressive timeline i
think
if
we're going to talk about enforceability
then i would i would admit readily admit
to you
that
2023 to begin a foundation to implement
in 2024
probably is not realistic
so it would be a conversation to have
with des as to what would be a realistic
guideline
of
making the appropriation in their budget
having it go through the house and the
senate and then actually
um you know once
if it's kept in the budget and signed
into signed into law by the governor
then it beca the onus becomes on des to
put together a set of criteria you know
and depending on what des in their
informed opinion would be
that would drive the criteria for person
working that job i think would
would take some time and as i think all
of us
small businesses today are struggling to
put people
in in in coffee shops i was i was at
einstein's and they only have one person
working the counter because the
two people that were going to be there
were out six so i think
that that is analogous to are we going
to be able to find somebody that's going
to want to apply for the job to be able
to do the job that we're tasking them to
do so i think the timeline
based on
how i how i
wrote the law is is overly aggressive
and i certainly would want to circle
that back to a more appropriate timeline
where
criteria can be created
processes and protocols can be created
and you know putting out the appropriate
um
one ad for for assistance and so that
des can actually interview and vet
candidates that would be appropriate so
it's a fair question and i appreciate it
thank you
um
how is maine funding its uh
legislation if i remember correctly
governor mills appropriated 40 million
dollars
and i
i don't
again
i'm relying on
testimony that i read and also
quite candidly the portland press herald
and the
lewiston sun journal 4 for the reporting
that occurred but it was governor mills
that appropriated 40 million dollars
but i think the 40 million was combined
with two other pfos bills that passed
simultaneously as part of a larger
package
so it's a fair question i'd be more than
happy to figure out what was the total
dollar amount appropriated to getting
that program up and running
you're welcome representative woods
uh thank you mr chair um if i could ask
and thank you for taking my question
my question is would you believe a very
famous philosopher who said this is deja
vu all over again
as opposed to vujo day that some of this
has never happened
uh this is um would you believe this is
a very similar problem
to lead
yes
we're going through the same process
would you believe that we had a product
lead which was in paint made some of the
best paint we've ever had
we had it in our water pipes
we had in our gasoline and we had to
make that societal determination
that that was no longer
compatible uh with our societal goals of
health and would you believe that this
is exactly the same process i agree i
i don't disagree with your doctor dr
representative and i would say
to amplify that des still has a lead
remediation program that they're still
managing in new hampshire and they are
still removing lead paint from houses
not just you know down here but also up
in the north country
on commissions okay there you go
thank you
okay well thank you very much for your
testimony okay again my apologies to my
colleagues no problem
uh
okay so now we have uh department of des
there we go
for the record my name is mike wimsett i
serve as director of the waste
management division for new hampshire
des and with me today is amy russo who
is our pfas programmer coordinator at
des
we appreciate the opportunity to testify
on house bill 1589.
uh to be clear we're not taking a
position on this bill um but we did
identify some concerns uh and i think
representative boyd the sponsor uh
highlighted some of those um that we
wanted to share with the committee and
first of all i want to say i want to
thank the sponsor representative boyd
has been a great leader in the merrimack
area
where we have a lot of pfas problems
that we've been dealing with
the agency has been struggling with and
working very hard to address
very widespread pfas contamination in
groundwater both on the seacoast and in
southern new hampshire since 2014 and in
southern new hampshire since 2016. so
this is something that has dominated
much of our time and resources for for
good reason
and
i want to emphasize that we do support
really any efforts that can help to
reduce exposure of new hampshire
citizens to pfas
uh having said that the concerns that
we've identified for this bill are
related as it's been discussed already
to resources it's a it's a um
as representative boyd indicated sort of
a cutting-edge bill doing something
that's not really being done in other
parts of the country yet
and that maine was the leader on
we
we have some history in the program in
the department of dealing with a similar
program and that would be with mercury
and switches and mercury added products
which we worked on many years ago so
this is not something that we would be
unable to do but i think as the bill is
crafted um it is uh as has been
discussed a little bit ambitious in
terms of timing that it would require us
to set up a program
uh do uh rule making do a lot of
outreach and then get going by january
23 which would be a given that this bill
had passed would likely be signed into
law in uh in the summer of 22 um that's
going to give us very little time to get
underway so if if a bill like this were
to pass we would like to see much more
realistic timelines in it
um
you know and i guess if you think about
the way the budget process works we'll
be working on a budget this summer for
implementation in uh you know the new
the new budget biennium would start in
july of 23.
so um or excuse me july 24 so so you
know if we looked at something where we
could work our
our needs and our resource requirements
into the budget that would make it much
more easy for us to to implement it um
i'll also mention that regionally um
there are some uh programs that that
could make implementation of this kind
of legislation much easier for
individual states if this is something
that were to happen across many states
or regionally or even nationally
there is precedent for
organizations that do the kind of data
collection that we
that would be required by a bill like
this and centralize that manufacturers
tend to like that because then they have
one reporting authority they can go to
and it covers them for the whole country
or the region so that's something that i
think you know new hampshire is not
typically on the bleeding edge of these
kinds of uh of uh
initiatives um we're going to be
watching and i i have you know
colleagues in maine that i'll be
communicating with as they go through
this implementation process and i'm sure
we'll learn a lot
but having said that that really
describes our concerns about uh
about this bill and we'll be happy to
okay representative hebert
have you had the time
to research whether or not there might
be federal funds
similar to the
efforts like brownfields efforts or
other efforts that have been funded in
the past
is there anything
uh
in that area that the funding might be
able to
assist you know our ability to to do the
what the cleanup is
it is possible we've not done any of
that research yet but that's certainly
something we could look at
representative abel
yes thank you very much for coming and
testifying
i wonder
since we've had experiences with
lead and with mercury
whether
this is um is
would would
pardon me would whether we would be
better off
trying to deal with
prohibiting the sale
of products that
have that contain pfas or should we be
spending our time
first on
on waste on
on containing
it once it's no longer when it's thrown
in the you know then
in the dump or wherever it goes
well thank you for the question yeah and
in essence for for really um
we started working pretty hard when we
determined that there was groundwater
contamination in peace the peace trade
port in 2014
but that was largely a superfund effort
and then in 2016 really it just
with what happened in southern new
hampshire and the widespread detection
of groundwater and drinking water
contamination
that's when we've been you know really
uh
putting all the resources we could
possibly put to pfas and and that and
most of that work has been about in the
first instance making sure that people
aren't drinking contaminated water that
if they're well's impacted that they in
the first instance get drink you know
bottled water or some kind of treatment
on and then we've also been working and
with
significant success but we've got more
to do
in extending public water systems for
connection for people to connect to
so that's been our primary but in the
process of that we've also looked at you
know what we have at our landfills we
know as representative boyd indicated
there's substantial contributions of
waste that go into a landfill that do
contain pfas we have had all of our
operating landfills and a number of
closed landfills where we still can get
a leachate sample sample their leachate
for pfast and uniformly we find pfast in
all of the leachate from all those
landfills
so we're looking at that and basically
the way that leachate is handled right
now
it is typically collected at a landfill
trucked to wastewater treatment
facilities and then integrated into the
wastewater treatment facilities influent
for treatment
those processes don't really effectively
treat pfas compounds what they really do
is distribute some of it to the to the
sludge and some of it goes out in the
actual water this just wastewater
effluent that's discharged in most cases
to a river as a receiving stream
that's the bad news the good news is is
that in those cases we are not seeing
resulting concentrations in those rivers
that that that cause concern having said
that it's still not a good story right
and so we're looking at determining what
we can do
to control that at the source at least
at the source of the leachate we're
looking at issues of you know and there
are already um one or more facilities in
new hampshire that do some form of
leachate treatment prior to sending it
to a wastewater facility so that's
something that's still a work in
progress but
the short answer to your question is yes
we need to be looking at that waste
well yep representative billiam
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um is the timeline um the
implementation of this bill the only
concern you have at this point
i think the primary i think the primary
concern is the timeline
i would also say that
it's never
new hampshire has often benefited from
not being on the cutting edge of these
things we have
seen programs implemented by other
states watched and learned from them and
then in many cases been able to come in
a little bit later and and and implement
a program that's more effective so the
timeline is our primary concern
um
we're not taking a position on the bill
so
i'm not sure there's much more i can say
got one more card here
david jewett
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuve i'm a senior vice president for
public policy with the business and
industry association
which serves as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce for the next
three weeks i'm also serving as interim
president for the association or role i
will be happy to give up in early
february
thank you for the opportunity to testify
i've handed out
my
testimony so i
won't read from it because i know that
you're interested in getting on to your
next hearing in a timely manner
the bia is opposed to this legislation
because we think it's not ready for
prime time and
one of the
individuals on your committee asked what
i thought was a really good question
which was did the sponsor reach out to
any other stakeholders or entities or
the des or anyone who might have been
able and willing to work with them on
this legislation to craft something that
better able for the state to implement
and
what we're most worried about with the
bill as is drafted is the impact that it
would have on so many products that that
are a part of our everyday lives and
also products that will be a part of our
future especially those concerning
sustainable energy products
so i would urge the committee to
be cautious with this
far-reaching legislation
and i would invite the sponsor um
i don't i don't want to suggest a study
commission because i've been around a
long time and and
we you know the less we say about study
commissions the better
you don't have to have a study
commission
uh
we're able to pull together uh
manufacturers who will have impact we're
able to put we the bia is able to pull
together
members from the american chemistry
council who will have important
information
the sponsor can bring to this group
impacted individuals i was a
resident of merrimack for 10 years so
you know i understand the significance
of the impact of this issue in in that
area and and the importance
with finding a solution moving forward
we just want to make sure that the
solution is the right solution
so i'd invite the sponsor to reach out
to us get us all around the table this
is not the type of thing that can be
done in in one meeting but we're all
willing to sit down
and try and come up with
legislation that i would characterize as
being ready for prime time
mr chair i
will be happy to try and answer any
questions the committee might have
yes
b leo thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question
uh your comment was about the um
impact on products and manufacturers
um can you comment on the impact on
human health
i
cannot except to recognize that that
pfas has been identified as having an
impact on on public health and i'm not
trying to minimize that representative
polio i'm suggesting
that this is an issue we should all be
working on
to to make improvements and several
products containing mercury brown fields
there are solutions that are available
and i believe that to be true with pfas
too
i think that it will require a
thoughtful
process with all stakeholders to make
sure that any legislation emerging from
that is good legislation that is taken
into
best information on that issue
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
our questions certainly uh you had
mentioned uh it could have an effect on
our future the products that we use in
the future could use the library just
for my own curiosity you mentioned it
could
affect products that deal with
sustainable energy yes uh thanks for the
question um
on the second page of my testimony
i uh
photocopied for for your information
a page that was provided to me by the
american chemistry council that tries to
demonstrate
the
vast array
of products
that
where there's a pfast component
and one of the products i learned about
recently
is is products related to offshore wind
development
and that is certainly
a a
exciting prospect we're in the very
early stages of that but we don't want
to
unintentionally pass legislation
that would uh act as an impediment from
from
great thank you very much thank you
so anybody else would like to testify on
house bill 1589
seeing none uh the blue sheets we have
fox love oh david l okay
love it's uh in support and mark brown
from the alliance for automobile
innovation which is opposition
and
uh
overnight we had 14 support and none
opposed
and with that i will close the public
hearing
thank you very much mr chair
it's uh
delighted i'm delighted to uh to be here
be back in the third floor be back with
the commerce committee
and uh miss you guys a lot and as i was
sharing with the
with the chair just a few minutes ago
that um that the experience my
experience on the commerce committee
with with 60 70 plus bills every session
has served as a wonderful training
ground for the education committee with
103 bills um this term so
so anyway thank you mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
dave luno i represent the people of
hopkinton and concord
and and serve on the the education
committee
it's important i think to lay the
lay the context
but here in new hampshire we're in a
public health crisis
that nobody could have imagined even a
few years ago
substance use disorders anxiety and
stress at home
in schools and in the workplace
health care workers at the end of their
rope
emergency rooms at capacity all behind
all beyond anyone's imagination
so here comes house bill 1622
and it really uh addresses three core
elements
the first
is enforcement of mental health parity
laws the second
is reimbursement rates
are part of that parity
and the third
is is it provides accountability to
patients and providers
through uh private right of action
so i'd like to address each each of
these three
uh core elements um uh specifically
the first one enforcement
the bill ensures enforcement of the
mental health parity and addiction
equity laws that we have
established here in new hampshire
simply put insurance carriers shouldn't
treat folks with mental health or
addiction health care
needs differently than folks with other
health care needs
insurance carriers might say they're
already doing this
and the insurance department might say
they aren't receiving any complaints
but the fact is
one of the largest carriers in the state
is not being fair to patients or
providers and in many cases has failed
to provide timely what are called
remittances
to mental health care providers
many of these practitioners are solo
and these remittances could include uh
payment
of the of the services covered by
insurance or an explanation of why the
claim was denied
but no remittances at all
nothing
no explanation for months
the carriers know this is happening
they're meeting with the providers to
try to settle them down
when providers take on a patient with an
insurance card
they expect to be paid
and then nothing no payment no denial
nothing
and patients are strung out for months
and maybe they're on the hook for paying
a denied claim
or maybe it's better not to seek
treatment at all yeah that's what some
patients are thinking maybe it's better
not to seek treatment at all
so among other things
house bill 1622 sets up a real and
meaningful complaint process
so people and providers can actually
have access to justice and parity
it's about respect
back to the core things this bill does
number two
it makes clear that reimbursement rates
for behavioral health services are part
of parity
in person and remote
mental health care reimbursements
reimbursements should be treated on par
with physical health care reimbursements
not slowed down not denied because the
visit was performed remotely and not
held in limbo
and finally number three
it establishes a private right of action
for people and providers to be able to
enforce the pre-existing requirement
that medicaid expansions reimbursement
rates for behavioral health
are at a level ensuring access and
capacity
new hampshire is one of only four states
that do not allow people to hold the
insurance department and carriers
accountable to follow state laws
i've been in this committee before to
improve consumer protection law
laws the chair knows this
and
my my work with rsa 358-a
to give granite staters the right to
challenge the insurance department or an
insurance carrier in court
but compared to that this is a light
touch
under very narrow in very specific
conditions
and if the insurance department is
already enforcing the law they shouldn't
have a problem with this
accountability to our constituents is a
good thing
so please consider house bill 1622 as a
positive step to help granite staters
it puts some teeth into the mountain
health parity law
and it gives patients and providers a
path to the quality of care we've all
paid for
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
representative burroughs thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question which is
when you talk about the complaint
process is that strictly for an
individual patient or does it cover is
this brought more broad in terms of the
carrier or population population health
or is it just for individuals no it's
it's for both both individual patients
as well as providers who feel that that
the insurance department needs to
intervene on their behalf
so
you're saying you're not sure whether
this is a problem or not that you imply
that the department
is actually doing something about
enforcing no i'm not unsure that it's a
that it's a problem or not because i've
heard specifically from solo
practitioners that that they're in fact
not receiving admittance uh remittances
from
um from from uh carriers
and um and so i don't know what the
department has um has received uh on
this or what interventions the
department
has has done on behalf of uh of these uh
mental health um practitioners okay so
you say remember
so they're not paying at all or they're
only paying partially not paying
full amounts so what was that yeah thank
you for the question mr chair when they
don't receive a remittance at all
they're not getting any payment at all
or even an explanation of a denial
because the remittance
can
include a payment but it could also
include a reason why there's not nothing
opinion yeah
it's my understanding
okay
and this is uh
anecdotal that you've heard that this is
what's occurring
and that when you ask the these
physicians that have they followed up
and they say they get no answer from the
insurance department
no response i i don't know if they've
contacted the insurance department um
specifically on on this i know that they
and and i had it my testimony
that uh that they have actively been um
been in communication with with a
carrier on on this uh on this subject
but uh to my understanding there's been
no resolution okay
representative
johnson
thank you for taking my question is this
one particular insurance company or is
this multiple insurance companies uh i'm
thank you very much for the question
representative johnson um
i'm aware of only one carrier one
insurance company on this but but it
could be more i don't have
okay so do you want me to go through
your pile
first and then however you'd like to
have that insurance that unnamed
insurance company come up or do you
weave them right in
okay yeah we're great so thank you very
much mr chair always a pleasure
chair we'll call on paula rogers from
anthem
yeah you gotta push the button
and then
pull it close to you yeah
can you hear me now yes i'm sorry thank
you so good afternoon commission
representative chairman
my name is paula rogers and i am here on
behalf of anthem but i'm also with
sabrina dunlop who i'd like to come up
because of the issue that's been raised
about claims payment and that is an
issue directed at anthem and sabrina
will have information on that my
intention today was to come and talk a
bit about the bill itself and they're
two separate matters it may not sound
like that but it is uh this the issue
that anthem is having has nothing to do
with mental health parity it has to do
with our systems
and we own that problem
so someone else
so i think to just sort of clarify
the bill and the relationship to the
claims issue i think sabrina who's
internal to anthem and i am not now i
used to be is probably better positioned
to give you
some sense of what that is all about
what measures are taken
being taken by anthem and how we are
working with the provider community very
aggressively to settle this matter
so sabrina i'm going to turn that over
to you thank you for letting us be here
as a duo i'm sabrina dunlap
um
so i'm happy to talk to anyone in more
detail about this but generally
what i think representative luna was
referring to are some widespread
operational issues anthem has had
end of summer into fall
i believe we have fully turned the
corner on those issues they did result
in delayed claims payments in some cases
as paula said nothing to do
with the parity issue it was a
anthem operational issue
so
um
we just had our third
town hall today
for behavioral health providers to come
and speak to anthem about any ongoing
issues they continue to have
as paula mentioned we have been doing a
lot of outreach to them
to make the situation right
and i think
that we have made a lot of progress
but again i think that that is a
completely separate issue from what is
before you
with this proposed bill
and i might pick up on that because the
only way you could conclude that
that issue has something to do with
parity is if anthem were willfully
willfully saying we're just not going to
pay these claims and i can assure you
that is not the issue at all
anthem was in the midst of i think the
last of commercials
in the anthem network there were 14
states moving to the new system and it
was moving away from something i
remember called asus and going to wgs
and quite frankly it was
very very choppy and we own that as i
said in my initial statements
now kind of putting that aside the
reason sabrina asked me to come this
morning or this afternoon was because i
have some
some history with the mental health
parity issue i certainly am no expert at
all it's just by working at anthem for
the number of years i did i saw the
iteration of the mental health parity
federal provisions called mapia
is the initials it's a mental health
um
it's mental health
i don't know
mental parity and and
equity
addiction act mental health parody and
an equity addiction act and mental
health parody first passed its very
first bill was way back in 1996 and then
in 2008
a broadened measure was passed that's
when sud came into the mix and mapia
became the sort of language about how
plans needed to
simply step up to the plate and pay sud
and mental health providers construct
their plans to make sure that as their
certificates of coverage were reviewed
that it was very clear that the
treatment opportunities for med surg
conditions behavioral health and sud
were comparable
that gets you to 2008 at that time it
only really covered group plans of 50
members or more and it was only with the
affordable care act when essential
benefits became part of compliance for
plans that were going to meet the
affordable care act standards they had
to include mental health and sud
coverage as an essential benefit and
that's when individual plans and small
group plans that were going to be sold
after 2014 and certainly going to be
sold on the exchanges had to come into
to compliance with mental health parity
since that time
plans have been struggling i think
regulators have been struggling to try
and set up a construct where
an inquiry being made by a
patient
a provider
a company a plan sponsor even a
regulator could go and look for guidance
on how to make sure that plans were
living up to the expectations
if you were to go on the websites of cms
the department of labor even the
treasury department you can find all
sorts of guidance again directed at
patients
plan sponsors insurers even state
regulators giving advice on how the
regulator can be assuring that when they
are overseeing an insurance operation
that they have their finger on the pulse
and know what's going on and can be able
to check with that pro that insurance
provider
re review that insurance provider's
performance through an examination or
more casually
and simply say yes indeed they are in
compliance with the act now in new
hampshire the regulator in 2017
announced exams of three carriers
to see whether they were compliant with
the mental health uh parity act
that was anthem
and harvard both in the room today there
was a third carry that may not be in the
room today
that examination went on for 18 months
to two years
and ultimately a letter was and you can
find it on the department website was
issued that the department and the plans
had settled
that the only concern that the
department had at that time related to
one of the things that's brought up in
this bill which is reimbursement and i
think the department is still doing
a final analysis of reimbursement but to
my knowledge at least anthem has no
feedback from the department that there
is any issue with anthem's reimbursement
under mental health parody and while the
department was doing this the
legislature was not entirely silent so
if you go back to i think it's senate
bill 217 272
in i think it was probably the
19 2019 session there was a bill that
basically
states very directly that the department
has the authority to move forward
and look to make sure that
the insurers that it supervises are
compliant
with the federal mental health parity
act so that's an express
maybe unnecessary grant of authority but
it's in there and it has uh house senate
bill set 272 from that session
and additionally there was one other
bill and i think it was 1632
from which session was that
in 2020
which if you look at the bill before you
i want to ask you to turn the page
and look at
section roman v
b
oh you're looking for the statue oh
excuse me
okay so if you look at the bill before
you
you will see that if it
amends
a section of new hampshire law
and you will look to see the section two
of the bill on page two at line nine
it amends 417 e12
you can see that on line nine
that section
has also
was amended in
on the bill 16 20
to include language
that goes into some detail
about how reimbursements are to be
looked at by the regulator
so you would have to go to the entire
provision in the new hampshire insurance
code
and i find it strange that this bill
comes before and doesn't actually give
you the entire statute because if you
were to go further you would come upon
language that was in that second bill
that i referenced
and that i think that's all it is is
adding the word rates
yes but what i guess i'm trying to point
out is there was if you go in the whole
provision
that this bill
is amending
you will find language that was provided
several years back that goes to some
detail about how the department is to
look at reimbursement rates
and that's absent from this bill which i
think is somewhat confusing so when it
goes to a subcommittee you want to make
sure the subcommittee has the entire
section that this bill demands so that
you can pick up that additional language
because it goes directly to the heart of
how the department is to look at
reimbursement
the other thing that i think is
important to know that if you look at
federal guidance there's a difference
between reimbursement practices and
reimbursement rates
so the federal guidance always points
the regulator
and the plans we're trying to comply
to making sure that is there practices
and procedures that have to be equal in
treatment med-surg
to
sud and bh
when it gets to the rates
rates may be looked at and may be an
indicator to a regulator that there
should be further examination and i
think that is where the new hampshire
insurance department is now with its
present
market conduct
focus
and so
when that is being looked at the
provision i talked about that you would
see if you saw this entire section to
which this bill applies you would see
that that section has three or four
paragraphs talking about what the
measurement is for the department at
that time
so tyler brannan is here and he can
certainly talk to you about where the
department is with his exam but i think
it's important to know that
that anthem's
concern with the bill is that it's using
rates rather than reimbursement
procedures
and when you talk directly to rates and
you will see that in
paragraph
line line 15 and
line 15 yes the word
and then you will see in many places in
references to rates
but you will see it in a strange way it
so if you look at for example on page
two roman
five
um it says behavioral health
reimbursement rates shall be no less
extensive
than those provided for physical illness
i mean that's just very vague language i
think
introduces unnecessary
ambiguity into a process it's already
and finally i guess one comment about
the authority of the insurance
department at present
there is certainly significant
discretionary authority at the
department level
the bill that i
referenced that was passed in
2019 also gives direct
regulatory authority or directive to the
department to enforce the
mental health parity act
one thing that did come to my mind when
representative luna was speaking is if
you look at line 17 of the bill i
thought that anything after line 17
actually
uh applied to the granite advantage
program so when he talked about a
private right of action i was quite
confused as to what that meant and there
was a question about who would have a
private right of action i would say in
what setting is another question
and as far as a private right of action
for the average
consumer out there right now the way the
department's
enforcement is structured it's largely
under the unfair insurance trade
practices act concept where the
department can bring an action of some
kind against a producer or a company
but the individual consumer does not
have a direct avenue through the
department to that
possibility of a recovery
the only way they can is if in under the
unfair insurance trade practices there
is a finding at the department they can
then use that finding in a court setting
to go further but it's not a direct line
for a provider to pursue now the
department really will respond to
provider complaints and it does
participate in provider
insurer issues and when
representative hunt asked about whether
the department was aware of the anthem
issue sabrina can talk that directly
because there have been conversations
with the department about this issue
yeah again i'm happy to talk to anyone
offline about this there's a lot to
discuss but yes the department's fully
aware we're in regular contact with them
and like i said we're in regular contact
with providers as well around these
claims issues
i just don't think they have anything to
okay
any questions from the committee members
thank you very much thank you
uh so tyler why don't you
come up now that we've heard
both sides of the issue and
thank you tell us how you're still
standing in the middle here
it's a common place to be so tyler
brandon life and health director with
the new hampshire insurance department
and i'm going to cover a few things
fortunately paula saved me
some time talking about the market
conduct examinations we did and where we
are today which we've been in a
monitoring period as a part of that exam
which means that we're still following
the exam process which has the
confidentiality of the exchange with the
carrier and has a certain process we
need to follow that in this case has
actually taken a year so it's um i think
it's unfortunate in terms of being able
to tell the public or tell the carriers
or advocates where we stand in a public
setting and hopefully i can say a little
more about it in a week or so but uh i
think the point is this conversation is
going to continue um this is not
something we're done with as a state
regulator but as it relates to the bill
we see this bill as really having two
major components to it and the first is
about our authority to enforce mapia or
i'll refer to it as sort of the parity
requirements because as paula mentioned
the parity requirements actually stem
from a couple of different federal laws
including the aca the good news is that
the legislative new hampshire
legislature passed
legislation that gives the insurance
department the authority to enforce both
nepea and the aca so we're in a good
place today
we do run into the common problem that
exists with all new hampshire insurance
laws for the self-insured employers and
for those that side of the of things
which is half the people who walk around
with insurance cards the department of
labor has direct regulatory authority
over those employers and the benefit
designs that exist so there is reference
to getting support from the department
of justice we feel as though we have the
authority to enforce empia the aca and
relate the laws the department of labor
has the authority as well on the
employer side so we don't feel the need
to involve the department of justice
from authority point of view
resources are always a concern and
indeed while we don't have a position on
the bill
satisfying the requirements in this
legislation as is described in the
fiscal note would require bringing on
three newer people
on the life and health side the
insurance department in market conduct
we have five so you'd be quite an
expansion of our existing staff
the other piece to the bill is about
provider reimbursement
and i think that paula rogers did
describe kind of the dynamic that exists
there as it relates to parity and it is
a common misunderstanding that the mepia
or the aca or related laws do require
insurers to pay mental health providers
at the same level as physical health
providers and that's not the case it
does relate more to the policies and
practices related to reimbursement and
whether or not that results at the end
of the day and reduce coverage on the
mental health side because remember
parity is about coverage it's not about
making sure providers get paid enough
so i think to the extent that there is
language in here requiring sort of
parity and reimbursement to mental
health providers with physical health
we would need a lot more legislative
direction than what is here to get i
think that the outcomes that are perhaps
hoped for with the bill provider
reimbursement and parity is kind of an
ill-defined concept you're clearly
dealing with different kinds of
providers doing different services often
not physicians even on the physical
health side of things there are a number
of different specialties that are all
paid at sort of varying levels for what
could be considered similar services
one of the common benchmarks that's used
is medicare let's say okay well let's
give everybody the same amount above
medicare does that mean then we're going
to end up with the same fee schedule for
all mental health providers is there
going to be certain assumptions about
the physical health providers are you
going to combine all the physical health
providers and come up with some sort of
average or are you going to pick a
specialty like primary care are you
going to adopt all the medicare
reimbursement policies that go with the
reimbursement levels there are a lot of
considerations in this i mean just to do
a simple analysis and say mental health
providers have paid 110 of medicare pcps
perhaps 180 of medicare that's sort of a
blunt tool but we have done that kind of
analysis but actually enforcing a
requirement for reimbursement parity
would be something different and we
would need a lot more detail and as you
can imagine fleshing out those details
is going to be very controversial
because you are talking about how much
um one of the things i would say though
is that the legislation does talk about
a reporting requirement and compliance
reports coming to the department these
reports becoming public
the day today we are looking very
closely at what the department of labor
is requiring of carriers employers in
terms of in terms of reporting
demonstrating a comparative deny a
comparative analysis that shows
compliance with parity x
mapia and the aca we're actually working
with the department of labor to make
sure our efforts are aligned with what
they're doing the idea being if the
carriers have to produce this kind of
information at a federal level and
create the system to do so we want to
piggyback on that as much as possible
and not create a different standard
that's going to be more research
intensive but exists for the same
purpose which is demonstrating
compliance in fact we have requested
legislation to clarify new hampshire
statute that we're moving that direction
and it's a senate bill that hopefully
will be coming over here
happy to take any questions that i think
representative
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh you always explain things very well
and i i appreciate that i think we all
do
i just want to check to see
if uh
if the only changes
in the
only thing that this bill would change
would be
the uh
the words in uh in bold boldface
in other words it would add
it would add the word rates
in
section two on page two
and
uh the sentence at the bottom
uh
and if if if that's correct if that's
the only thing that is being changed
from
uh what what was what's currently in
effect uh what what are what are the
implications of that and if if i'm wrong
about what's changed would you please
explain that
so if i understand you're talking about
on page 2 line 15 where rates is added
you made reference to another section
below the other one is with the granite
advantage
program
if you're just asking about adding rates
to that paragraph that i think raises a
number of questions about what it means
and what the expectation is
so as a regulator to be able to enforce
that i think we'd be put into a place
where
we're making a lot of decisions without
okay
got it great thank you
thank you
uh okay now we'll go back to the story
good afternoon mr chair honorable
members of the committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
and new futures as many of you know new
futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
health policy and advocacy organization
we've been working for more than 20
years to address substance use and
mental mental health issues in our state
i'm here today not just speaking on
behalf of new futures but on uh
thousands of granite staters who don't
feel they can safely access the
legislature and attend hearings in
person during this stage dangerous phase
of the pandemic
i don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said this afternoon but i do
want to stress new future strong support
for this bill
as you know our state has worked
tirelessly in recent years to build a
behavioral health treatment system
capable of overcoming the ongoing
addiction and mental health crises that
our stage is facing
overall treatment and recovery programs
have come a long way but mental health
parity remains one of the single biggest
obstacles we face in our efforts to
overcome these crises and provide
treatment services to all those in need
as you've heard today federal parity law
requires insurance carriers to cover
mental health and substance use services
the same way they cover medical and
surgical services
in recent years the insurance department
has been working to ensure compliance by
educating consumers reviewing regulated
insurance plans and investigating market
conduct
still
frequently we hear from patients who are
denied coverage patients or providers
who are denied coverage or reimbursement
for essential mental health or substance
use treatment services
this not only leaves individuals facing
a hefty hefty medical bills that they
struggle to afford but it serves as a
key deterrent to continued treatment
which can lead them to defer medical
care until a period of crisis in which
they're treated at an emergency room or
other high cost locations
this leaves our health care system with
considerably higher costs and leaves our
state caught in the perpetual in these
perpetual behavioral health crises
this bill proposes to address these
concerns by providing the insurance
department with important additional
tools to better enforce parity
compliance
it would strengthen the department's
ability to support consumers to review
an investigation of complaints and
alleged parity violations and it would
require our insurance carriers to make
compliance reports available to the
public increasing transparency and
consumer confidence
together these steps would help the
department and insurers and our state as
a whole to provide equal access to
critical mental health and substance use
treatment and to move forward in our
battle against these behavioral health
crises
representative spagnolo a great friend
and ally recognized the need
whose
name is on this bill recognized the need
for equal access to these services and
he spent much of his time and energy
working to increase access support and
resources
this is this bill is a great way to
honor his legacy and to continue the
battle he devoted so much of his life to
with that we ask you to vote
this bill ought to pass and i'm happy to
i think we're all set thank you thank
you
uh holly stevens who used to be new
futures and now you're nami
good afternoon
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee
and i just want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify today yes i am
the same person but now i am the
director of public policy for nami new
hampshire
the national alliance on mental illness
nami new hampshire is a non-profit
non-partisan organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide through support education
and advocacy and on behalf of army new
hampshire i am
here today to speak
in favor
of this bill
you've heard about the
mental health parity act so i'm not
going to go into any details on that i
think we've covered that today
and you also i laid out some of the
background regarding the market conduct
uh study that the
insurance department did in my testimony
um
i think one of the the biggest concerns
is that
um that that market conduct analysis did
it looked at reimbursement rates
and when it saw that there might have
been a discrepancy
there wasn't really a finding of
discrepancy but they asked the providers
to
show them their policies
for how they calculated
payment reimbursement for mental health
providers
and
i correct me i mean i know paula will
correct me if i'm wrong here but
that
the insurers weren't able to provide
those to the satisfaction of the
resulted in the settlement agreements
that the department has with anthem and
and to date
as you heard from mr brannan
no information
regarding those settlement agreements
has been made public
um all we know is that there was a
potential finding
they are supposed to provide information
but in no way
know whether there has been compliance
or if there is compliance with the
and
you know i think you've also heard today
that it it's well known that new
hampshire
is in the middle of a mental health and
substance use disorder crisis
part of this is due to
the shortage of providers
within
the mental health and substance use
disorder communities that are providing
services
for folks
in further compounding the issue
is the number of mental health providers
who have opted not to accept
and part of that is due to lower
reimbursement rates
and also
the the complications with the billing
and another issue that nami new
hampshire is very familiar with
is something that
we describe as ghost networks
and what these are is if you look at the
networks
of providers that the insurers have
there's a large list of names
but the families
that nami new hampshire works with and
supports
have found that as they start calling
down that list that the insurers give
them
there are no therapists that are
accepting
any new patients
so if nobody's accepting any new
patients
not only are there not adequate networks
there's no networks at all um
and because they are able to produce the
names of individuals that they have
contracts with
and i don't i don't know i don't think
that the
insurers are aware of
the fact that the providers don't have
the the ability to take new patients i
don't think they're doing it nefariously
i think it's they've got contracts with
these providers um they submit those
lists to the department it looks like
there's an adequate network everybody
thinks there's an adequate network and
it's not an adequate network um and it
and it really flies under the uh the the
radar um and people are not able to
receive the services that they need
and a lot of that goes back to provider
reimbursements
because fewer and fewer
mental health providers and substance
use disorder providers are contracting
and so house bill
would
address reimbursements directly would
address the access
issues indirectly
because if you're able to increase
the reimbursement rates for providers
then more providers would
take commercial insurance
and it also does establish the complaint
process for providers and for
which would be separate and apart from
the regular
complaint process that the insurance
department has right now
so it would ensure that these
complaints
could receive priority they could be
parsed out
and it would also allow the insurance
department to see
if a lot of complaints were coming in
for a particular
insurance carrier
so it would make the the job easier for
the insurance department
so you know because of that i think it's
really important to to give strong
consideration to this bill and i don't
normally do this but i'm i'm going to
today
when i moved from
new futures to nami new hampshire my
insurance switched from harvard pilgrim
to anthem
i told my therapist that and she said
guess what
i'm not renewing my contract with anthem
their reimbursement rates are too low
they don't respond to emails and
sorry
i don't know what to tell you so
my provider of five years
i no longer have because
of reimbursement rates
and so if people don't think that this
is an issue it is an issue
it's a legitimate issue and it's not
something that you know
me as a
orange badge just come over here and
talk about you know there are real
people
that this is happening to
we here at nami i have experienced it
so with that i will end and i will take
i guess we're all set
uh
anita hansen
all right let's support the belt
this is a
this is my first time doing this in case
nobody can tell so
i'm getting it videoed
for
my people
just so you know this is uh available on
youtube this year oh i did not know that
yeah wow i bet you get tons of hits on
entertainment
i think other committees but ours is
never exciting enough yeah well
maybe today it will be
um thank you mr chair members of the
committee
i'm anina hansen i'm an alcoholic
and i was
phil spaniela's life partner and i have
brought him
to
be
the silent witness here today
i'd like to tell you a little bit about
i waited 42 years to find him
he waited 52 years to find me
we shared almost two years
of what we had thought would be the rest
of our lives
and we were happy
we met when we were both three years
clean and sober
he wowed me from our very first
conversation when he told me he ran
sober houses and that he had run for and
won
a seat in the new hampshire house on a
platform of addiction and recovery his
authenticity his transparency his huge
heart of service
won me from the start
his time in the new hampshire house and
his subsequent run for senate he lost in
2020 to harold french who's a great guy
was all about being of service
phil was particularly passionate about
the issues of addiction and mental
health he would have earnestly supported
this bill and the people it protects
he was ceaselessly courageous about
sharing his own history with those
challenges his decades of alcohol and
drug use
his depression and in particular his
anxiety which was a crippling force
throughout his life
what i didn't know until it was too late
was that even during those five years of
living sober and being a wholehearted
public servant and activist
phil's mental health was never really
managed
at the end of this past may he was
diagnosed with cancer
and he panicked
a few days later in the beginning of
june he relapsed and three weeks later
on the night of summer solstice he died
in a drug den in manchester
during those last three weeks he and i
had some heavy conversations and that's
when he told me his meds had stopped
working long ago he'd been
white-knuckling his mental health for a
long time
this man's entire life was about
recovery he lived and breathed sobriety
mental health awareness destigmatization
but he was much better at advocating for
others than for himself
when he realized long-term sobriety
still hadn't addressed his mental health
needs
he toughed it out in silence
by the time he finally told me he wasn't
okay it was too late
we got him in to see a new psychiatrist
but with his anxiety off the charts over
the cancer he ended up doing what we
addicts do
and he self-medicated
and long before his new meds had a
chance to kick in he was dead
i want to be clear there's only one
person whose responsibility it was to
keep phil alive and that was phil
he was an expert he knew what to do he
knew he needed to ask for help and he
waited way too long
but part of the reason he waited was
that he didn't believe help would be
there if he asked
when phil got sober at 48 he went on
medicaid for the first time in his life
but when he called to get an appointment
with a mental health professional he
couldn't find anyone accepting new
clients who took medicaid when he called
to see if he could get in a rehab for
the time being he was told the wait time
for a bed was six to eight weeks
he said i'll be out by then i'll be dead
he ended up going to the laconia mayor's
office and asking for an appointment
and when he got one he asked the mayor
how does a guy like me stay sober in
this town
the mayor told him
i don't know
and that's the problem
people want help they qualify for help
they even ask for help and they can't
access help
help isn't available
help will take too long
that mayor may have saved phil's life
that day by putting him in touch with
some people who were starting a recovery
center
phil got involved and he found a
lifeline to hold on to
service
a few years later during a tv appearance
he said
i don't know that i'd still be sitting
here today sober if i wasn't given the
opportunity to help others
if we don't help the ones who are still
suffering who's going to
if not me then who
that's the question i ask myself all the
time
and he did ask himself that question all
the time i saw it
and still it ended the worst possible
way for him
i have been angry at him for this
it was such a stupid way for such a
smart man to die
but i made my guy a promise
after he died
that i would remember him for his
greatness
and i do
his transparency his advocacy his
dedication to serving others
what a courageous way
phil was literally one of you
although he sat on the health and human
services committee
mental illness and addiction
look like this
like phil
good people
living good lives
doing their best
helping others learning to ask for help
and needing to know
that help will be available when they
mental illness and addiction when the
help people need isn't available to them
looks like me the widow for no good
reason
grieving every day not just the death of
the man
i wanted to spend my life with but the
terrible truth that his death was
preventable
it's too late to save his life
but not to save others
one thing i know for sure
my guy whose entire life was about
service to others
would want his death to be of service
too phil's life demonstrated the value
of legislation like this bill
if you don't help the ones who are still
suffering who will
if not you then who
thank you
thank you all for what you do to serve
our citizens and our state
and i hope you will all do one more
service for them
yep representative perez
um
first of all um thank you for letting me
speak
i want to take
a minute and say thank you
because it takes a lot a lot of courage
to come in and speak in front of us not
just in front of us but we have a lot of
people
listen and
see in this video
mental illness
is not an easy topic to speak about it
let me tell you i come from a culture
that mental illness is a taboo we're not
allowed to speak about it
and then a lot of times we don't get the
help that we need
but you strain and
the way you're speaking and i know that
he touched a lot of lies because
i have friends who live in laconia and
they know him and i know a lot of people
they've been touched by him
i'm so grateful you're here
and i'm so grateful for everything he
did and then you're speaking in front of
us
it's giving me the strength to continue
doing what i'm doing
i'm trying to speak up about mental
health i try to help others because we
have a lot of people that don't have
voices and we need those voices to be
here
thank you
thank you for coming we really
appreciate you
sharing that story
represent him did
you take one more question absolutely
thank you can you hear me now yeah you
might want to get closer to mike
thank you
thank you very much for your courage and
coming here to speak to us about such a
sensitive and personal
experience and loss
i i just want you to know i agree with
you 100 percent
that we are adequately
underserved
with
mental health
professionals
and services
and anything that you can do to continue
to speak up
is is very much appreciated by me
because we do have
way too few
mental health professionals in the new
hampshire to meet the needs
and it's just as important
a need
a health need
as all the physical
and medical needs are so thank you for
your courage
thanks
uh the chair will call on peter bragnan
uh thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record peter bragdon
representing harvard pilgrim healthcare
uh
testifying in opposition to hp 1622.
harvard pilgrim is the state's
only not-for-profit health insurance
company serving the individual and group
markets and the only insurance company
founded by doctors
while we've signed in in opposition to
h.b 1622 we fully understand how vitally
important mental health care is its
importance has been highlighted
particularly through the coven 19
pandemic
the concerns we have with the bill are
that its goals appear to be already
addressed in other parts of statute
therefore the bill is unnecessary
for instance section one of the bill
gives the insurance department the
authority to investigate insurance
carrier conduct that may violate the
federal mental health parity law
also known as the
mental health parity and addiction
equity enforcement law
which has been a tongue twister earlier
in the day as well
so the bill gives authority to
investigate conduct that may violate
that however has been mentioned by
tyler brennan amongst others that the
insurance department already has
investigational authority under
rsa400a16
which states the insurance department
quote may conduct such investigations in
addition to those specifically provided
for
as maybe found necessary in order to
promote efficient administration of the
provisions
the insurance department has examination
authority under rsa 4837 and they
recently committed completed as was
mentioned a market conduct exam of three
of new hampshire's commercial carriers
to ensure compliance with the federal
federal law
section one further requires that the
insurance department establish a
specific mental health complaint process
as has been mentioned the insurance
department already has a complaint
process which is managed by the consumer
services division a separate complaint
process specifically for mental health
parity is unnecessary it would be
confusing to the consumer
section one would also require insurers
to submit annual reports on their
compliance with the federal law
the recent federal amendments to the law
require plans to do an analysis of all
non-quantitative treatment limitations
to demonstrate compliance with that and
as tyler mentioned there's a bill in the
senate i think it's senate bill 373 or
343 373
that basically uh make some changes in
the state insurance laws to allow those
same reports to be submitted to the new
hampshire insurance department we should
be striving to align the federal
requirements rather than create new
requirements i just note that the
insurance department has filed this bill
in the senate
to be able to do that and finally the
bill would require reimbursement rates
for behavioral health care to be no less
extensive than rates provided for other
type of health care
the federal law already addresses how
insurance carriers should be addressing
reimbursement rates and we should not be
reinterpreting the law through the state
statute
so
one final note is the legislature uh
revisited the issue in 2020 has has been
mentioned already an added language that
requires insurers to include in their
contracts with participating providers
reimbursement terms for mental health
and substance use treatment that are on
average at least as favorable as those
in their contracts for professional
services uh provided by
non-hospital-affiliated pcps
this section of the law has only been in
effect for about 18 months so overall we
feel that the provisions in this
bill before you are already covered
and the insurance department has the
authority to do the things already
mentioned in here and adding yet another
layer of it will not prove helpful or
change anything be happy to take any
questions
representative greeson
thank you mr chairman and thank you sir
for answering our questions
we've heard a lot that reimbursement
rates are too low that's been testimony
from several people that they're too low
so how are reimbursement rates
determined
i am not sure internally how it all
works i know that's under the purview of
the
insurance department's review of the
mental health
provisions of the plans that the market
conducts study that apparently from what
tyler has said we'll be able to talk a
lot a bit more in a couple of weeks
so the federal law certainly dictates
the process by which rates are set uh
but i do not know internally how the
process actually happens i mean there's
there's contract negotiations obviously
with carriers and i do know that um you
know there's a lot of
leverage let's say that providers that
work for large hospital groups have
because network adequacy is required
that they have
over an independent provider it forces
that work as well outside of the
representative terry
thank you sir thank you for your
testimony um
i receive a lot of uh
email with um
copies of uh testimony
if you've already done so i apologize i
will check my email when i return home
if you have not done so would you be so
kind as to submit your written testimony
to the members of the committee yes
thank you and i will do that i have not
yet done that
so
is harvard pilgrim and the granite
advantage
no that's the medicaid expansion
there's just three companies and
yeah the managed care companies i
believe right right
i thought there was supposed to be a
non-profit they had to get a non-profit
into that there may be in that uh but i
in terms of the individual and um group
health insurance markets i believe we're
the only non-profit that covers all of
them right right
and of course medicare
okay
seeing on thank you very much thank you
very much
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee um for the record my
name is heidi kroll i work at gallagher
callahan gartrell and i represent ahip
which is america's health insurance
plans um
at this point everything i had in my
notes to say i think has been said and
so i i won't um
repeat what other speakers have said
ahip does have some you know significant
concerns with the bill um for the
reasons um
that have been expressed i think by
anthem and harvard pilgrim um just i
think in general concerns about um
duplication with what already exists in
federal and state law
and with duplication and trying to
reinterpret comes potential unintended
consequences that i think we just want
to be really careful about
as you've heard there's a lot of history
and there's also it's a very complicated
subject matter
and we have had recent legislation as
you heard in 2019 we had
senator morgan's bill sb
272 and in 2020 we had senator sherman's
bill which started out as sb 620 was
ultimately rolled into house bill 1639
that
addressed mental health parity under the
insurance laws uh and in both bills made
changes to certain sections of
rsa
417-e colon one which is um in your
in the bill you're looking at
um
and so that section of law now contains
language about reimbursement standards
for mental health and substance use
disorders and ms rogers was speaking
about this and i think from ahib's
perspective we're concerned that
really it's anything more than what we
have in current law relative to
reimbursement standards
uh could be starting down a slippery
slope of putting us in a territory of
actually rate setting and price fixing
which i think we just want to be really
careful
about that um all of the other points
that i was going to make have been said
so i will respect your time and not
repeat them
i just did want to respond to one
question um that representative abel had
about new language and um i just wanted
to point out that um all of page one in
the bill
um on to page two up to line eight that
is all new it's just not appearing in
bold because because all of it is new um
and what follows is um
existing law that is um proposing you
know the proposal to change so that
that's what you see in the bold so
um
i i did see mr chairman that you have
scheduled already a work session on this
um and i i know that ahip and ahip's
members will will be there and available
and uh willing to participate um so i
appreciate your time very much thank you
so before you go
i have a question
and that is an old subject matter that's
been around for a while
and it's a network adequacy
and terms of how we define adequate and
i think i got a letter from dj this week
or maybe i got it from
nick that said how great we are doing in
terms of network adequacy i think there
was a letter sent out at least i assume
and my question is
if
companies are listening names in those
physicians or those doctors they're not
taking new patients
in the age of computers now where we do
how difficult would it be for you to
actually make sure that the
listing of providers are actually
taking patients
that's a great question
i'm not prepared to answer that at the
moment it's just not my area of
expertise but
i think the carriers in the room have
heard the question and and i you know
the department here as well and so that
might be a question that we can answer
at the work session well as the
spokesman for all the companies
i'm urging you to uh kind of figure out
some ways we can solve this issue
um in terms of that when someone go you
know is looking for a provider
um they're not you know running around
calling calling calling that that the
network got exclusive is really actual
there's no ghost networks we need to
have real networks
or if they're closed they're closed but
then
then you it begs the question
uh whether you need to hire some find
some new page
physicians who
maybe you'll have to pay them more money
and that way you guys do it rather than
us mandating it
understood
fair point yes
all right thank you thank you
uh representative joy you're you're on
david's list but i didn't get a card
oh no that's it have a seat john i was
on that sea john
[Laughter]
sure come on up but you'll fill out a
pink guard actually i can just take the
back side of this card and fill it out
john dejoy
for the record my name is john dejoy and
i'm here representing the national
association of social workers as well as
the new hampshire psychological
association
both membership organizations that
represent mental health providers who
are have significant concerns about
parity
as well as delayed reimbursements
my clients asked me to come and gather
information today which is what i've
been doing
that's why i'm not prepared to make
comments but i do intend to attend the
work sessions and i'm happy to represent
my clients input at those sessions
have you ever heard mr chairman speak
for that little time
no john that's probably true
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
okay having no more cards i will close
the public hearing on
so for the committee members uh next
wednesday and next thursday
uh pay attention the wednesday we will
be doing the subcommittees and they are
broken up by
the times uh of uh which are the
we're just going to do subcommittees on
all the sub whether they're going to
meet
you'll see the schedule you know
they each there's each one has two bills
so they get